la séance est ouverte l'ordre du jour
appelle les questions au gouvernement
je vous rappelle les règles dérogatoires
organisation de nos séances de questions
raison de la crise sanitaire 75 députés
peuvent depuis la semaine dernière se
réunir dans l'hémicycle selon une
répartition proportionnelle aux
effectifs des groupes
ce nombre compte tenu des ministres et
des fonctionnaires permet de respecter
le décret qui limite à 100 personnes
les rassemblements en milieu clos sur le
territoire de la république
par ailleurs nous sommes revenus depuis
la semaine dernière au nombre habituel
de questions plus favorable au groupe
d'opposition les temps de parole sont
les temps usuelle des minutes par
question et autant par raiponce réplique
ou contre eux réplique éventuelles
comprises
lors de l'appel traditionnel des
questions et rétablit toutefois les
questions ayant le même thème sont
regroupés chaque question faisant
l'objet d'une réponse spécifique enfin
les règles sanitaires continue
naturellement à s'appliquer nettoyage
des micros en cours de séance les
orateurs sont invités à ne pas poser les
mains sur les micro et utiliser des
micros différentes respect des distances
entre les participants entrée sortie de
l'hémicycle échelonnée nous commençons
notre séance par des questions portant
sur la crise du coup vite 19 en général
et notamment le thème de la santé
la parole est à madame mathilde de peu
non monsieur le premier ministre
les masques tombent à mesure que les
masques manque
vous nous avez d'abord menti en nous
expliquant que tout allait bien alors
que les soignants manquerait cruellement
de protection puis que les masques ne
servait à rien vous avez menti pour
masquer la pénurie ses ordres et contre
ordres ont coûté des vies
les masques tombent et la vérité
aussitôt se dévoile vous ne contrôlez
pas la situation
vous avez refusé de réquisitionner les
entreprises de textile les couturières
ont dû pallier la défaillance de l'état
qui plus est sans être rémunéré vous
compter sur la solidarité pour combler
votre incompétence
aujourd'hui la colère se dispute au
dégoût des masques qui apparaissent
comme par magie
lorsqu'il s'agit de profits
il est de votre responsabilité monsieur
le premier ministre de fournir des
masques aux soignants ainsi qu'à
l'ensemble de la population
il est de votre responsabilité de tout
faire pour assurer la sécurité sanitaire
de la nation mais non vous préférez
laisser la grande distribution qui se
gavent déjà sur la fermeture des petits
commerces vendre des masques
chirurgicaux à des prix exorbitants par
centaines de millions d'où vient-il
comment la grande distribution c'était
le procurer plus de 400 millions de
masques aussi rapidement alors même que
le stock stratégique d'état est en
carence quand c'est leclerc qui commande
les masques arrive immédiatement quand
c'est l'état
il arrive en juin vous laisser les
profiteurs de crise décider du prix du
mas pour ne pas aussi de freiner
l'innovation
face au tollé aux abus ils seront
plafonnés à 95 centimes soit huit fois
plus cher qu'avant l'épidémie une belle
marge pour les actionnaires
le coût pour une famille pourrait être
de 100 à 200 euros de masse par mois une
ronde alors que la fin gagne du terrain
les plus précaires n'auront plus qu'à
choisir entre manger ou se protéger
il n'y a qu'un seul prix à fixer pour la
santé sa gratuité
les profits des actionnaires de leclerc
d'intermarché ou d'auchan ne valent pas
la vie de millions d'entre nous monsieur
le premier ministre
cc d'endosser le masque de la
déresponsabilisation
prenez la seule décision qui vaille
rendez les masses gratuit et distribué
les massivement la parole de monsieur
adrien taquet secrétaire d'état auprès
du ministre des solidarités et de la
santé merci monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les députés madame
la députée je constate bien depuis
quelques semaines depuis quelques mois
que ten théorie aux rouleaux aux relents
quelque peu complotistes ou la
diabolisation de tout ce qui touche de
près ou de loin au capitalisme nourrit
la matrice intellectuelle de votre de
votre parti mais madame la députée je
voulais sûr il n'y a ni stock caché ni
concurrence
les chiffres avancés par la grande
distribution que vous évoquez de l'ordre
de plusieurs centaines de millions de
masques chirurgicaux ne correspondent
pas à ce qu'il y ait en stock
aujourd'hui met aux commandes qui ont
été passées il ya de cela plusieurs mois
et qui aujourd'hui arrive en rayon
pour le bien et la protection de nos
concitoyens les enseignes reçoivent au
fur et à mesure à titre de comparaison
vous le savez les professionnels de
santé ont bénéficié de la commande de la
part de delta de près de 3 milliards de
masques ces deux derniers mois les
volumes annoncés par la grande
distribution montre ainsi pas en
concurrence avec notre système
d'approvisionnement du système de santé
qui est géré directement par santé
publique france nous importons
aujourd'hui 100 millions de masques
chaque semaine ce sont 45 millions de
masques qui sont distribués chaque
semaine pour les professionnels de santé
ce sont 100 millions de masques qui
seront distribués demain les entreprises
privées comme les collectivités locales
d'ailleurs dont je salue ici le travail
ont le droit d'importer des masses de
type chirurgical depuis le 21 mars
dernier
elles sont toutefois tenus de déclarer
toute commande supérieure à 5 millions
de masques sur les trois mois glissants
vous le savez mais il n'y a donc pas de
stock caché cette polémique n'a pas lieu
d'être
nous avons besoin de tout le monde pour
permettre aux français à l'ensemble des
français
le 11 mai de disposer de masques de
protection par ailleurs madame la
députée vous le savez un stock de 5
millions de masques ont été attribués au
ccas et aux mairies pour pouvoir les
fournir aux personnes les plus fragiles
je vous remercie monsieur le ministre
la parole est à madame marie thomas réel
verhaeghe
merci merci monsieur le président ma
question s'adresse au ministre des
solidarités de la santé monsieur
ministre
cette question est d'abord l'occasion de
manifester notre reconnaissance aux
pharmaciens parlant maillage territorial
ils permettent depuis deux mois
d'assurer la distribution d'outils de
protection aux soignants
[Applaudissements]
il endosse de nouvelles missions dont
celle de prévenir les violences
intrafamiliales et cela malgré des vols
et de nombreuses incivilités
ils sont un chaînon primordial de la
lutte contre le togo vit de 19 et nous
les en remercions
malgré vos explications et les appuis
scientifique pour éclairer la stratégie
de distribution des masses les
pharmaciens font face à des difficultés
de compréhension de la part des
soignants et de la population
aujourd'hui il souhaite d'abord de la
lisibilité quant à leur place dans le
réseau de distribution par rapport aux
magasins de la grande distribution qui
affiche l'acquisition d'une grande
quantité de masques chirurgicaux
plus précisément comment expliquer que
les officines qui sont en difficulté de
fournir les soignants en quantité
suffisante alors que des quantités
importantes sont déjà en vente au grand
public
d'autre part le fait que la grande
distribution dont ce n'est pas le coeur
de métier fournissent massivement des
masques pose la question du conseil et
de l'accompagnement pour le port et
l'utilisation à bon escient de ces
masques cela interroge aussi sur la mise
en place d'une communication adaptée à
l'échelle nationale les masques sont
aujourd'hui au coeur des préoccupations
des français face à ces différentes
problématiques d'offres de demande
d'attribution et d'homologation les
professionnels souhaiterait pouvoir
disposer davantage d'éléments de cadrage
et de doctrines qu'ils puissent
également partagé avec pédagogie à la
population monsieur le ministre
quelles réponses pouvez vous apporter à
ces préoccupations gérard merci merci
chers collègues la parole de monsieur
adrien attaqué secrétaire d'état auprès
du ministre des solidarités de la santé
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés madame la députée
marie tamarelle travers votre question
vous vous traduisez l'émotion des
soignants n'est plus largement du monde
delà de la santé je peux comprendre nous
pouvons comprendre les interrogations
les doutes les polémiques parfois qu'ils
ont pu surgir ces derniers jours mais je
pense je suis assez convaincu j'espère
que les interventions des derniers jours
et les éléments que je vais pouvoir vous
apporter aujourd'hui seront ils mettre
un terme
nous avons dès le début considéré que la
disponibilité en masse allait être une
problématique
dans la gestion de cette de cette crise
et comme de nombreux pays vous le savez
la france a dû gérer un risque de
pénurie de masques et depuis plusieurs
semaines nous avons mis tout en oeuvre
pour maîtriser ce risque et assure une
distribution régulière de masques aux
professionnels et les pharmaciens ont
joué joue un rôle clé vous l'avez
rappelé dans cette logistique et vous
avez raison aujourd'hui de leur rendre
hommage et je m'associe le gouvernement
s'associe évidemment à 7 à cet hommage
sur ces deux derniers mois je l'évoquais
tout à l'heure nous avons distribué 300
millions de masques aux professionnels
progressivement son 45 millions chaque
semaine
bientôt 100 millions je le disais et en
responsabilité les pharmaciens ont
assuré gratuitement depuis deux mois la
distribution de ces masques pour les
professionnels de santé de ville et en
responsabilité ils ont parfois même pour
la plupart d'entre eux réservé leurs
propres stocks de masques à ceux à ceux
qui en avaient besoin
et le gouvernement sait pouvoir compter
sur eux pour continuer à protéger
l'ensemble des professionnels de santé
pour répondre plus précisément à votre
question sachez que le 7 le jeudi 7 mai
prochain au soir de nouvelles dotations
vont arriver dans les officines et que
l'ensemble des professionnels de santé
ont reçu ce jour même un message de la
direction générale de la santé qui a
pour objet de répondre à l'ensemble des
questions qui sont soulevées sur la
fourniture de cette nouvelle de ces
nouvelles dotations et de l'usaj qui
pourrait en être faits notamment pour
accompagner la reprise d'activité merci
monsieur madame la députée oui merci
monsieur ministre espère qu
effectivement ces éléments d'information
pouvoir assurer les collègues de
pharmaciens et surtout qu enfin cette
tension puissent être levés de façon à
ce qu'ils se sentent tout à fait à même
d'accomplir leur mission un sérénité
auprès des soignants dont nous devons en
priorité la protection genre merci merci
chers collègues
la parole est un monsieur christian
jacob merci monsieur le président
monsieur le premier ministre
à quelques jours du processus de
déconfinement le doute est plus fort que
jamais ce doute s'est installé dès les
premiers jours de la crise sanitaire
il s'installe et parce que très vite les
français ont compris que nous n'étions
pas prêts
il s'installe et aussi parce que vous
avez changé d'avis sur beaucoup de
choses et souvent sur les masques sur
les tests sur l'ouverture des écoles sur
les mesures de quarantaine pour les
ressortissants de l'union européenne sur
la date du déconfinement tout le monde
comprend le doute et le doute est
légitime lorsqu'il précède la décision
mais les approximations les ordres et
les contreurs de vos ministres
les controverses entre et parfois même à
votre égard sont de plus en plus
insupportable à votre décharge le
président de la république ne vous êtes
pas au contraire par ses prises de
positions pour le moins évolutive
il vous a faibli à chaque à chacune de
ses interventions
pourtant monsieur le premier ministre
vous avez eu tout au long de cette
période une opposition parlementaire qui
a toujours été force de proposition qui
a toujours agi en responsabilité et des
élus locaux qui en permanence ont
cherché à combler les failles et les
faiblesses de l'état
mais où en est la france aujourd'hui
nous pleurons à ce jour trois fois plus
de morts que l'allemagne pour un nombre
de malades similaires notre produit
intérieur brut chute beaucoup plus vite
et beaucoup plus fort que chez la
plupart de nos voisins
et lorsque l'on demande aux peuples
d'europe s'ils sont satisfaits de
l'action de leurs dirigeants
le jugement est cruel merkel comptait
courte johnson tous font mieux
ma question est donc simple sur le
premier ministre pourquoi ces mauvais
résultats
et quels enseignements en tirez-vous
merci chers collègues la parole est à
monsieur le premier ministre le
président mesdames et messieurs les
députés
monsieur le député je ne vais pas et
vous évoquez beaucoup de sujets dans
votre question je peux pas les traiter
tous ici mais je voudrais dire que votre
question ad'abord le l'immense mérite
de nous imposer un exercice qui est
délicat en ce moment mais nécessaire et
qu'il faut prendre avec humilité
prudence celui de la comparaison
internationale
il s'agit pas de comparer ce qui n'est
que très peu comparable mais c'est utile
en effet de regarder comment confrontés
à une menace identique avec parfois des
taux de prévalence différents maires
fine menace identique les différents
pays d'europe ont réagi comment leur
système de soins s'est adapté comment
les décisions étaient prises
vous dites pour le noter et pour en
critiquer le gouvernement français ce
qui est parfaitement votre droit que
l'allemagne a observé un nombre de cas
inférieur un nombre de décès est très
largement inférieur et qu' elle devrait
donc être un exemple est allé à bien des
égards un exemple je peux parfaitement
l'entendre et partager cet avis avec
tout vous ne dit pas en revanche que la
comparaison avec les autres pays
comparables à la france n'est pas sur
tous les points
forcément aux désavantages immédiat je
le dis avec une prudence infinie
s'agissant de la façon dont l'épidémie a
été géré vous dites que les populations
estime par exemple que le premier
ministre britannique a beaucoup mieux
géré que la situation en france
peut-être sans doute c'est un point de
vue l'opinion publique mais je le dis
aussi peut-être mais je crois qu'à la
fin car un moment nous pourrons regarder
dans le détail avec la sagesse de du
regard rétrospectif et avec l'ensemble
des données
comment notre système de soins s'est
adapté à la crise et comment celui des
pays comparables soumis aux mêmes stress
soumis aux mêmes pressions a réagi je
vous dire monsieur le président jacob
j'attends ce jour avec sérénité non pas
du tout avec
bravoure ou avec un quelconque
enthousiasme mais j'attends ce jour avec
sérénité
j'observe que le système italien qui a
souvent été décrié à tort car vous savez
comme moi que la lombardie qui a été la
plus marquée par cette épidémie est une
région riche une région remarquablement
équipée y compris en matière de services
publics et humains y compris en matière
de services publics sanitaires et bien
ce qu'on observe c'est que le système
italien
confronté à cette terrible épidémie
s'est retrouvé dans une situation où il
a dû effectuer le fameux est terrible et
tri des malades
s'agissant de l'entrée en réanimation ce
qui n'a pas été le cas en france parce
que notre système a tenu
probablement parce qu'il a eu un petit
peu plus de temps pour s'adapter
d'ailleurs que celui de nos amis
italiens quand une fois je ne cherche
pas à dénigrer nos amis tout le monde
est dans une situation difficile en
italie en espagne au royaume-uni qui
sont disons le dpi par la taille par
l'histoire par l'organisation
relativement relativement comparé et
donc je le dis avec tranquillité avec
humilité je sais très bien que on peut
toujours aller chercher l'exemple qui
fonctionne mieux je pense qu'il faut
aller regarder et qu'on verra à la fin
on verra à la fin comment les allemands
au passé cette étape on verra quand
l'ensemble des données sera disponible
comment ils ont passé cette étape et je
vais vous dire s'ils n'ont pas c'est
mieux que nous eh bien d'abord je m'en
réjouirai pour eux car ce sont nos amis
et ensuite comme vous comme nous tous
ici
j'essaierai d'en tirer les leçons ce que
nous pouvons apprendre de leurs systèmes
pas simplement dans la gestion de crise
dans bien d'autres aspects comment est
ce que nous pouvons améliorer notre
système ce temps viendra vous avez
raison monsieur le député jacob sur le
président jacob
il viendra aujourd'hui nous sommes dans
la gestion encore de la crise sanitaire
avec des étapes très compliqué qui sont
devant nous il ya beaucoup de gens qui
savent parfaitement que préparer le
déconfinement c'est encore plus
difficile que de décider le confinement
beaucoup plus difficile logistiquement
juridiquement
politiquement humainement techniquement
c'est très difficile c'est le travail
que nous sommes en train de faire et
quand je dis nous ce n'est pas à nous de
majesté il ne s'agit pas de ça c'est les
préfets et les élus locaux
c'est les chefs d'entreprise c'est
l'ensemble des acteurs du système de
soins qui essaie d'organiser les choses
pour pouvoir se conformer ou pour
pouvoir mettre en oeuvre de la façon la
plus intelligente possible les éléments
doctrine sanitaires ou d'organisation
collective qui ne sont pas faciles à
mettre en oeuvre j'en ai parfaitement
conscience parce qu'il n'est pas facile
de contrôler une épidémie
or nous devons la contrôler la contrôler
sans traitement efficace sans vaccin
sans immunité collective et donc c'est
un exercice difficile et moi dans cet
exercice difficile
j'essaie dans toute la mesure du
possible mais ça n'est pas simple et
vous savez que ça n'est pas simple et
d'ailleurs vous l'avais dit à juste
titre d'apporter les éléments dont
disposent dont doivent disposer les gens
quand ils prennent les décisions pour
les mettre en oeuvre
j'essaie de faire en sorte que la chaîne
que les chaînes départementale qui
permettront de remonter les chaînes
contamination puisse être cassée de
façon à ce qu'on évite la propagation de
l'épidémie
j'essaie de faire en sorte que
l'approvisionnement en test soit
suffisant il sera techniquement
suffisant pour pouvoir là aussi éviter
la propagation de l'épidémie
c'est ce que fait le gouvernement
français monsieur le président jacob
britannique le gouvernement espagnol le
gouvernement italien ils le font tous
dans des conditions politiques
différentes qui sont parfois très
critiqué en interne ils sont très
critiqués vous avez cité les bons
chiffres
je regarde ce qui se passe dans les pays
amis au royaume uni en italie en espagne
en belgique
très critiqué par tous parce que tout le
monde a peur et parce que tout le monde
sait bien que nous vivons quelque chose
de retour dablement complexe il n'est
pas impossible que j'en terminerai par
là monsieur le président jacob que dans
d'autres pays que le nôtre
je veux dire autrement je rencontre
beaucoup j'ai beaucoup de témoignages de
nos concitoyens qui sont très en colère
mais qui en veulent beaucoup au
gouvernement j'ai aussi beaucoup de
témoignages de gens qui disent c'est
horriblement difficile ce que vous êtes
en train de faire et ce qui est en train
de faire monsieur le maire ou madame le
maire c'est horriblement difficile de
prendre des décisions en ce moment et on
le sait tous donc allez-y courage tenez
bon il ya des pays où on le dit
peut-être plus publiquement que chez
nous c'est vrai c'est comme ça nous
vivons en france nous aurons des leçons
à retenir de l'expérience que nous
vivons des difficultés que nous vivons
elle commanderont beaucoup de lucidité
et beaucoup de travail en commun et je
suis évidemment prêt merci monsieur le
premier ministre la parole à madame anne
brugnara merci monsieur le président ma
question s'adresse au ministre de
l'éducation nationale le 12 mai nos
enfants reprendront le chemin de l'école
ce sera un moment fort dans la vie de
ses élèves bien sûr et un moment
symbolique d'un déconfinement progressif
redonnant vie à nos territoires par
l'ouverture d'un lieu primordial de
notre société
l'école du quartier ou du village c'est
surtout un moment essentiel pour la
continuité pédagogique des enfants qui
vivent déconfinement différents selon
leur lieu d'habitation
selon la compagnie ambre
l'accompagnement pardon que chaque
parent peut apporter dans nos
territoires ce sont bien les maires et
leurs adjoints à l'éducation qui sont à
l'oeuvre pour ouvrir des infrastructures
dont ils ont la compétence mais la
politique d'opposition systématique a
repris et des voix se font entendre pour
ne pas rouvrir ses premiers lieux de
savoirs de citoyenneté que sont les
écoles publiques françaises
en tant qu'élu local ancienne adjointe
aux écoles membres de la délégation aux
collectivités territoriales je trouve
paradoxal d'entendre régulièrement des
élus locaux demandé plus de
responsabilités plus d'autonomie est de
constater que le jour où ils ont
l'occasion de le faire ils en appellent
à l'état
je veux m'adresser à eux à l'heure où
notre nation demande un discours clair
et un travail en commun
soyons soyez au rendez vous travailler
avec nous avec vos services académiques
pour laisser le choix aux parents le
choix aux parents de maintenir une
instruction à domicile ou de re
scolariser leurs enfants car ce choix
leur appartient
mais l'arbre ne doit pas cacher la forêt
et je tiens à remercier ici tous les
maires tous les élus tous les services
qui travaillent à cette réouverture en
respectant le protocole sanitaire
fournis par l'éducation nationale en
achetant les protections nécessaires aux
agents et aux enseignants en préparant
les salles de classe en recensant avec
les directeurs d'école et capacités
d'accueil et les choix des familles pour
préparer au mieux cette reprise pour
réussir ensemble ce retour à l'école il
faut que chacun enseignants comme élu
travaille en confiance en souplesse et
sortent des schémas habituels parfois
bien rigide mais rossi soleil
comment vos services soutiennent ces
bonnes voulons la parole à monsieur jean
michel blanquer arménie de l'éducation
nationale et de la jeunesse
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés madame la députée
brogniart votre question est importante
dans un moment décisif pour notre pays
parce que ce que nous avons à faire
chacun le sait est totalement inédit
c'est la première fois dans notre
histoire que l'éducation nationale doit
faire une rentrée pendant l'année
scolaire et c'est la première fois aussi
qu'on doit le faire dans ce format là
qui est inédit et qui vous avez raison
on appelle à beaucoup de souplesse
locale il ya trois choses trois défis
que nous devons relever un défi
sanitaire
c'est le sens du protocole sanitaire il
est très stricte je le reconnais s'il ne
l'avait pas été on nous l'aurait
reproché
maintenant il l'est certains trouvent
qu'il est trop stricte mais nous
assumons il est stricte mais nous sommes
tous ensemble pour le faire respecter et
aider les communes à pouvoir évidemment
se mettre à jour
deuxièmement il ya un cadre d'accueil
c'est à dire définir dans quel ordre
viennent les enfants c'est pour ça qu'on
a défini à la fois des niveaux mais
aussi des publics prioritaires
et puis en troisième et un cadre
pédagogique parce que l'école n'est pas
une garderie il va se passer
pédagogiquement des choses importantes
au mois de mai et juin
si nous avons un objectif social ça va
avec notre objectif pédagogique c'est à
dire assurer que les enfants évidemment
apprennent et se développent pendant ces
mois de mai juin l'enjeu social il est
fondamental et vous l'avez très bien
rappelé on ne peut pas se permettre
d'avoir des enfants qui ne soit pas à
l'école du mois de mars jusqu'au mois de
septembre
cet enjeu social nous sommes en train de
le relever j'étais ce matin avec le
président
blick à poissy qui est un très bon
exemple de cette forêt qui ne saurait
être cachée par l'arbre comme vous avez
dit parce que en effet là on a fait
l'accueil des enfants de soignants
l'accueil des enfants de soignants ne
l'oublions pas ça s'est réalisé pour
trente mille enfants pendant les deux
mois de confinement et ça a été réussie
et magnifiquement réussie par tous les
mairies les enseignants les personnels
et et j en ai eu le témoignage tout à
l'heure ça servait évidemment aussi pour
penser le déconfinement et cette école
comme bien d'autres en france comme la
majorité des écoles de france et bien
ouvrira au cours du mois de mai pour
tout simplement accueillir le maximum
d'enfants
alors oui les choses ne sont pas comme
d'habitude je crois que chacun peut le
comprendre mais nous montrerons que nous
sommes un peuple uni autour de l'école
si nous réussissons ce déconfinement
avec toutes les mairies mais je sais que
nous y arriverons merci monsieur le
ministre
la parole est à monsieur marc le fur
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
premier ministre je me fais ici le porte
parole des populations de notre littoral
mais aussi des élus de toutes
sensibilités rassemblés sur cette
question ils ne comprennent pas que nos
plages restent inaccessibles
après le 11 mai le président de la
république nous avait promis un
déconfinement qu adviendra-t-il la
plupart des départements littoraux sont
en effet au vert c'est le cas en
particulier des cinq départements
bretons l'ouverture de nos plages est
donc possible et souhaité en particulier
par les professionnels du tourisme qui
ne peuvent pas avoir d'activité on le
comprend bien en ce moment mais qui
verrait dans cette ouverture un signe
tout à fait positif après des
difficultés qu'ils traversent
premier message d'espoir il faut en
finir avec cet interdit de principe
en quoi les plages seraient tels plus
dangereuses que les transports en commun
ou que les grandes surfaces les plages
sont accessibles en grande bretagne
elles le sont également en italie
l'ouverture de ces plages bien
évidemment s'accompagnerait d'une
réglementation très stricte afin que la
distanciation entre les personnes et les
groupes soient respectés mais nos plages
sur nos plages et nos grèves sont vastes
cela pourrait le relever de la
réglementation des mères qui déjà on le
sait dispose du pouvoir
6 par pitié monsieur le premier ministre
arrêtez de tout décider de paris écoutez
le local écouter les élus qui côtoient
les populations et connaissent les lieux
cc d'infantiliser nos compatriotes qui
ont su faire preuve de plus grand esprit
de discipline si chers collègues la
parole paire dames christelle du boss
secrétaire d'état auprès du ministre des
solidarités de la santé merci monsieur
le président mesdames et messieurs les
députés le premier ministre a indiqué
ici dans cet hémicycle la semaine
dernière que par mesure de précaution en
effet des plages resteront inaccessibles
au public au moins jusqu'au 1er juin
chacun mesure le caractère contraignant
de cette règle notamment pour ceux comme
vous l'avez dit qu'ils vivent sur le
littoral et qui souhaiteraient pratiquer
des activités aquatiques et nautiques
le gouvernement est aujourd'hui le
garant de la prudence et de la
progressivité avec lequel la levée du
déconfinement levée du confinement
pardon doit s'opérer
nous devons veiller à tout prix assurer
le respect des règles de distanciation
physique qui avec les autres mesures
barrières sont nos meilleurs atouts pour
faire reculer l'épidémie
nous avons entendu les arguments
développés par ceux qui souhaitent la
réouverture
plusieurs évoquent l'idée de permettre
l'accès aux plages pour pratiquer un
sport comme en australie sans autoriser
l'installation d'une serviette
à ce stade il semble plus raisonnable de
maintenir la règle annoncée par le
premier ministre
la première phase du déconfinement nous
impose une vigilance et une prudence
particulière
nous devons tenir compte de l'expérience
dès que l'accès aux plages sera ouvert
il y aura un souhait de s'y rendre en
nombre
or ce sont des espaces qui sont
difficiles à surveiller et à contrôler
enfin la période qui s'ouvre comporte
plusieurs jours fériés qui accroissent
le risque d'une présence massive sur les
plages et si l'action n'était autorisée
nous sommes bien conscients du caractère
contraignant et de la déception qu'elle
engendre nous avons trois semaines
devant nous trois semaines puisque nous
avons convenu de réexaminer ce point en
vue de
diame étape de la levée du confinement
soit le premier jour je vous remercie
merci madame la ministre
trim et notre déception madame la
ministre après votre réponse
les plages sont vastes les grèves sont
vastes
on peut parfaitement organisé une
réglementation as extract tout en
permettant au moins l'accès aux
marcheurs ou sportifs
les gens ont besoin effectivement d'un
peu de la capacité de serre merci
monsieur le fur la parole est valable
après s'il vous plaît la parole est à
madame la présidente valérie rabault
vous avez la parole chers collègues si
monsieur le président monsieur le
premier ministre perd c'est lui que la
crise que nous vivons est très complexe
à gérer mais parce qu'elle est complexe
il nous faut des réponses claires et
surtout qui ne se contredisent pas selon
qui de vous de vos ministre ou du
président de la république les formules
aussi en ce cinquantième jours de
confinement je souhaite des réponses
claires il semble que dans votre
gouvernement certains de vos ministres
estiment qu'à partir du 11 mai lutter
contre la crise économique
l'emportera sur la lutte contre la crise
sanitaire est ce votre cas
nous nous pensons que lutter contre la
crise sanitaire doit demeurer la
priorité y compris après le 11 mai
c'est pour cela que nous voulons des
masques pour tous en vendant l'assemblée
nationale ce jour je me suis rendu dans
une dizaine de pharmacies à paris est
une grande surface
aucune n'en avait j'ai finalement fini
par en trouver dans une onzième
pharmacie pourriez vous nous préciser
monsieur le premier ministre
quelle est la diffusion des masques sur
le territoire et comment vous entendez
réguler cette diffusion
deuxième question nous souhaitons une
reprise colère sécurisé nous estimons
que le principe doit être on ouvre quand
on est prêt en matière de sécurité
sanitaire
nous estimons également que l'état doit
assumer sa part de responsabilité et
arrêter de se défausser sur les mers
c'est pour cela que je vous demande que
la réouverture des écoles fassent
l'objet d'une validation préalable de
l'état
kiko assumera la décision de réouverture
sur proposition du maire
c'est pour cela que vous nous voulons
des tests pcr vous avait annoncé mardi
dernier un objectif de 700 mille tests
par semaine ou à partir du 11 mai or
selon le président du syndicat national
des médecins biologistes les
laboratoires publics et privés ne
réalisent ensemble qu environ 250000
test chaque semaine en ce moment comment
envisagez-vous de multiplier ce nombre
par trois d'ici mardi
lundi prochain un dernier mot sur la
sécurité économique cette fois financer
les plans d'urgence suppose de sécuriser
notre accès aux financements j'ai posé
deux fois la question au ministre de
l'économie et des finances qui n'a pas
répondu
ce jour la cour constitutionnelle
allemande met en garde la bce sur
financement qu'elles accordent quelles
garanties avez vous obtenu auprès nos
partenaires européens
je vous remercie merci valeur présidente
la parole est à monsieur le premier
ministre monsieur le président mesdames
et messieurs les députés mme la
présidente
beaucoup de questions là encore dans
votre question je laisserai le ministre
d'économie des finances aborder le
dernier des thèmes que vous avez
évoquées je voudrais répondre d'abord à
la première question que vous avez
formule est celle de savoir si à compter
du 11 mai le rang de nos priorités se
trouverait changé j'avais cru être clair
monde exprimant la semaine dernière à
cette tribune peut être ne neige pas été
suffisamment si ça n'est pas le cas je
vais essayer de leur faire en étant
suffisamment clair pour que chacun
puisse comprendre nous avons nous sommes
sur une ligne de crête
je préférerais que les choses soient
plus simples madame la présidente
oui mais je vous aussi d'ailleurs nous
tous mais elles ne le sont pas simples
nous sommes sur une ligne de crête
si nous allons trop vite dans le
déconfinement nous risquons de mauvaises
nouvelles sanitaires j'en ai la
conviction et donc je suis prudent et
j'ai indiqué que les choses se ferait
progressivement
parfois cela m'est reproché parfois
certains disent
vous devriez aller plus vite ouvrir les
cafés-restaurants autorisé leur
ouverture
ouvrir les plages on l'a entendu à
l'instant de la part de monsieur le
député le feu non nous voulons allons
progressivement pour vérifier qu'à
chacune des étapes que nous passons nous
sommes capables de maîtriser le virus
est aussi vrai que nous devons être
prudents nous ne pouvons pas rester
immobile parce que sinon c'est un autre
risque que nous devons auxquelles nous
allons devoir faire face
un autre risque celui de très mauvaises
nouvelles économiques pour le pays celui
de l'effondrement de la production de la
capacité de la redistribution celui
d'une catastrophe sociale à la sortie
celui d'une catastrophe pédagogique et
tous s'y risque voulait mesurer
parfaitement
il faut donc que nous ayons une démarche
progressive et prudente qui nous
permettent de garantir la sécurité et de
faire repartir notre pays
c'est un équilibre difficile mais je ne
crois pas madame la présidente que ce ne
soit un équilibre qui ne serait pas
clair il est difficile à tenir mais nos
concitoyens ne comprennent parfaitement
ils comprennent parfaitement qu'il nous
faut avancer mais qu'on doit avancer
prudemment
voilà alors après chacun se fait une
idée de ce que ça veut dire avancer et
avancer prudemment et c'est vrai que
soit parce qu'on se trouve dans un
territoire où le virus a plus circuler
que dans un autre on se dit l'équilibré
c'est plutôt plus avancée mais je peux
parfaitement comprendre ça tout le monde
peut le comprendre mais c'est cet
équilibre qu'il faut tenir et c'est cet
équilibre que nous essayons de tenir en
retz où vivent les écoles en faisant en
sorte que les transports en commun
puisse
progressivement mais avec des mesures
très contraignantes c'est vrai faire
face à l'augmentation du trafic
c'est comme ça que nous étions tenir
l'équilibré voilà ce que je voulais
répondre à votre première question et
tout le gouvernement est sur cette ligne
alors bien entendu parfois certains
mettre l'accent tonique sur une mesure
qui relève plus du redémarrage ou qui
relève plus de la prudence et mes
commentateurs
j'ai pas votre cas madame la présidente
mais les commentateurs disent à la
différence fondamentale dans
l'expression c'est pas vrai nous sommes
en train de tenir un équilibre nous
essayons de tenir un équilibre nous
savons que ce n'est pas facile
et au fond ce que nous demandons et nous
le demandons l humilité c'est un peu de
bonne foi de l'autre côté
et encore une fois je ne parle pas de
vous madame la crise entre 1 2 c'est un
peu de bonne foi quand chacun comprend
que nous sommes dans cette logique de
l'equilibre de bonne foi alors chacun
comprend comment on peut essayer
localement d'appliquer cette décision
c'est ce sur quoi je veux insister en
réponse à votre question
s'agissant de la distribution des
masques nous avons indiqué et le
gouvernement a indiqué un certain nombre
d'éléments qui permettent d'envisager la
façon dont les masques vont être
distribués nous avons indiqué qu'il y
avait des canaux de distribution
différents pour les professeurs et pour
les élèves de collège qui à partir du 18
mai dans les départements verts vont
reprendre le chemin de l'école
quand je dis les professeurs c'est
l'ensemble de ce qui contribue à la
pédagogie dans les établissements
scolaires c'est l'éducation nationale
qui verse acquis qui fournira les
masques voilà un élément de distribution
c'est évidemment dans le cadre de sa
fonction d'employeur que l'état donnera
à ceux qui servent l'état
un certain nombre de masques les
entreprises pour un très grand nombre
d'entre elles ont passé des commandes et
vont fournir à leurs salariés des
masques mais vous savez que dans un
certain nombre de branches
professionnelles les branches se sont
organisés pour que les grandes
entreprises puissent fournir leurs sous
traitants
les petites entreprises qui parfois ont
plus de mal à commander de façon à ce
que là aussi la chaîne de production les
comptes certaine façon la chaîne
économique la chaîne nationale puisse
tenir et s'équiper également indiqué
vous savez que les collectivités
territoriales auprès des initiatives
très nombreuses et tant mieux c'est pas
elle contre l'état c'est tout le monde
ensemble qui doivent essayer de trouver
des mesures pour
pour passer cet état et les
collectivités territoriales ont eu mille
fois raison d'essayer de s'équiper dans
toute la mesure du possible pour
distribuer selon des critères qui leur
sont d'ailleurs propres ces masques à
leur population avec des canaux
différents mais qui sont adaptés à la
réalité du terrain
c'est vrai au havre comme c'est vrai
partout en france c'est vrai dans toutes
les villes qui composent toutes les
circonscriptions que vous représentez ou
parlant de pardon parce que vous ne
représentez pas de circonscriptions pour
représenter le peuple français
où que vous soyez et comme ça on va
réussir à équiper l'ensemble du
territoire madame madame la présidente
le fait que la grande distribution que
le commerce en général et commandé des
masques et les vendent
mais c'est une bonne nouvelle il ya
beaucoup de produits de première
nécessité qui contribuent très fortement
à la sécurité qui contribuent très
fortement à la vie qui sont en vente
dans les commerces
c'est vraiment beaucoup et c'est très
bien ça permettra à beaucoup de nos
concitoyens de pouvoir accès rapidement
à un produit qui est devenu nécessaire
pour ceux qui n'y auront pas accès à
travers ces canaux
le secrétaire d'état le ministre des
solidarités de la santé oms indiqué j'ai
moi même dit que chaque semaine nous
veillerons à ce que 5 millions de
masques puisse être répartis dans les
départements pour essayer justement de
trouver au cas par cas lorsqu'on aura vu
des comment dirais-je des parties de la
population qui n'auraient pas accès
parce qu'elles sont les plus fragiles ou
les plus éloignés qu'elles ne pourront
pas se tourner vers la grande
distribution ça peut arriver qu elles
n'auront pas les moyens de se tourner la
grande distribution ça peut arriver
qu'elle puisse disposer de masques et ce
sont les préfets dans leurs départements
qui vont au mieux répartir ses basques
et je ne peux pas vous dire département
par département comment ils vont faire
peut-être que vous dénoncerez le flou de
ma réponse mais si je commençais ici à
dire comment les tous vont être
distribués département par département
d'abord je ne tromperai et ensuite ce ne
serait pas adaptée à la réalité de
chaque département
c'est comme ça progressivement le plus
vite possible que nous allons équiper
notre pays
en répétant et de façon systématique
madame la présidente que le masque est
un complément aux gestes barrière qui
doit être bien porté et qui ne peut être
qu'un complément gestes barrière car il
est encore plus important
même si ça donne le sentiment d'être
contre intuitif il est encore plus
important d'observer la distanciation
physique et de se laver les mains à
intervalles très réguliers
merci monsieur le premier ministre la
parole et à monsieur christophe
madeleine merci monsieur le président
chers collègues
monsieur le ministre de l'éducation
nationale pourquoi avez vous décidé de
remettre les plus petits en premier sur
les bancs de l'école et surtout dans ces
conditions une majorité d'autres pays
vous le savez on décider soit de
repousser la rentrée en septembre soit
de commencer par ceux qui peuvent
adopter les mesures sanitaires de base
ce le premier ministre l'a dit tout à
l'heure dans d'autres termes mais
comparaison n'est pas raison mais le
néanmoins la singularité de la france a
de quoi inquiéter
comment peut-on imaginer des enfants de
maternelle pour qu'ils puissent
comprendre et respecter le maintien de
la distanciation physique et
l'application des gestes barrières
ces deux fondamentaux que vous citez
dans le protocole sanitaire édictées
pour la réouverture des établissements
sont irréalisables avec des enfants de
moins de 10 ans vous prenez donc le
risque de multiplier de nouveau cluster
avec deux potes des porteurs de virus
asymptomatiques
monsieur le ministre avez vous
conscience aussi du malaise des
professeurs le personnel de l'éducation
nationale a fait un travail magnifique
le corps enseignant et je tiens à lui
rendre hommage a répondu présent depuis
le début de cette crise sanitaire pour
être au plus près des élèves et les
accompagner mais aussi dans la prise en
charge des enfants dont les parents
étaient mobilisés ils étaient
volontaires pour reprendre les cours
mais au vu de la préparation et des
annonces changeantes du gouvernement on
comprend leur angoisse grandissante
partagée d'ailleurs par les parents
d'élèves
monsieur le ministre à quelques semaines
de la fin de l'année scolaire
quels sont les arguments pédagogiques
pour cette rentrée précipiter monsieur
le ministre
où est donc le bon sens dans votre
décision
merci chers collègues la parole était
monsieur jean michel blanquer ministre
de l'éducation nationale et de la
jeunesse
merci monsieur le président messieurs
les députés monsieur le député
christophe naegelen vous avez fait de la
comparaison internationale je peux en
faire aussi il ya beaucoup de pays qui
ont choisi le déconfinement et beaucoup
de pays qui s'engagent à faire
scolariser d'abord les élèves à l'école
primaire je pourrais vous fournir une
comparaison mais la france n'est
absolument pas dans une situation unique
donc je n'y a aucune raison de décrire
les choses autrement mais je ne vois pas
pourquoi vous l'avez fait en soit
ensuite quels sont les arguments il ya
un argument social est un argument
sanitaires
l'argument social je l' ai dit tout à
l'heure et je le répète à partir du
moment où l'on considère que l'école est
absolument indispensable c'est encore
plus vrai pour les enfants les plus
jeunes
le décrochage à l'école primaire est la
chose la plus catastrophique qui puisse
arriver et ça existe malheureusement
même si on a réussi à en réduire le
nombre
et donc c'est évidemment fondamental en
second lieu d'ailleurs parce que nous
avons pris la mesure de dédoublement des
cp et de ce1 par deux ce qui représente
300 mille enfants parce que nous avons
une politique favorable pour le milieu
rural
vous avez 60 mille enfants du milieu
rural qui sont dans des classes de moins
de 15 élèves nous pouvons faire entrer
ses élèves assez directement dans les
temps prochains en respectant le
protocole sanitaire
enfin il ya des arguments sanitaires
gelé mentionne toujours avec précaution
étant moi même pas un spécialiste mais
enfin les dernières études montrent
qu'il ya une contagiosité moins forte
chez les moins de 10 ans que au delà et
donc jeu j'en ai aussi j'ai aussi des
éléments comme ce matin dans cette école
de poissy à laquelle je faisais
référence où les personnels se sont
engagés je vous rassure ils se sont
engagés pour l'accueil des enfants de
soignants il s'engage avec le même
enthousiasme ensuite ça ne sert à rien
de décrire les choses de façon
pessimiste
lorsqu'on voit des acteurs comme ça qui
en effet sont à saluer mais qui partage
le même optimisme que moi sur
l'engagement des professeurs et bien ce
ses personnels pas un n'a été malade
pendant cette période
ce que j'ai vu à poissy pas un enfant
n'a été malade donc ça ne sert à rien de
noircir le tableau
bien sûr il faut être prudent il faut
être prudent c'est ce que nous faisons
avec le protocole sanitaire
encore une fois parfois on nous reproche
qu'il soit trop strictes mais ça ne sert
à rien aussi de nier tous les problèmes
qu'il y aurait si les enfants restés à
l'école jusqu'au mois de septembre et à
l'école primaire elle est une priorité
hors crise
elle est encore une priorité même dans
la crise merci monsieur le ministre la
parole est à monsieur sébastien jumel
le premier ministre êtes vous étonné que
deux tiers des français sera opposé à la
réouverture des écoles le 11 mai alors
que nous vivons une crise sanitaire sans
précédent nous pas ce délai c'est un
président en solitaire omnipotent qu'il
a décidé contre l'avis des scientifiques
peut-être même contre votre avis à vous
et depuis c'est le branle bas pour se
conformer à l'injonction irréaliste qui
se moque des familles des maires et des
enseignants face à cette situation
cette annonce précipitée a été adoucie
en invoquant le volontariat
l'école de la république sur la base du
volontariat
à chaque jour son concept désormais
c'est la lutte contre le décrochage
scolaire
sur la base du volontariat dans quel
salon doré at-on adapter ce concept de
l'argumentaire exécutif les mères à qui
l'état a repassé les plats grâce à cette
notion hypocrite de volontariat les
mères seules face aux inquiétudes de la
population sur les conséquences
possibles du coc vide chez l'enfant
reçoivent une semaine avant le début du
déconfinement un protocole certes
complet mais technocratique
il n'est plus inaptes les câbles qui se
résument ainsi posé l'enfant sur une
chaise immobile à l'écart des copains
des jeux avec l'obligation de se laver
les mains
tous les quarts d'heure le contraire de
l'humanité quotidienne de nos atsem des
ash aux côtés des enfants handicapés
l'incarcération ce n'est pas l'école que
l'on veut pour nos enfants me disait
hier un maire faute d'une véritable
concertation en amont les conditions ne
sont pas réunies pour une reprise à la
date
inventé par le président de la
république et vous le savez beaucoup de
questions at on des réponses cantine
transports scolaires des infections
accueil périscolaire qui fait quoi
comment chaque jour et avec quels moyens
pour les collectivités il est encore
temps d'y répondre par un soutien
concret du terrain il est encore temps
de décider que la validation des plans
de reprise seront faits par les
représentants d'états monsieur le
premier ministre le crédit de l'état
s'est fracassé sur les masques
sur l'hôpital évitons qu'il s'abîme sur
l'école de la république
merci chers collègues la parole est à
monsieur jean michel blanquer ministre
de l'éducation nationale de la jeunesse
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés monsieur le député
sébastien jumel sur tous les sujets que
nous abordons en matière de déco
finement il faut toujours aussi résonné
à contrario qu est ce que vous auriez
fait si vous aviez fait le contraire de
ce que nous avons décidé
est-ce que vous aurez à laisser les
enfants à la maison confiné y compris
les plus défavorisés dans des
appartements et 3 jusqu'au mois de
septembre
avec quelles conséquences sociales une
fois que vous auriez décidé ça
qu'auriez-vous fait au mois de septembre
est ce que vous auriez décidé d'obliger
les parents à envoyer leurs enfants
vous auriez envoyé la police chercher
les enfants dans leurs familles pour les
obliger à venir à l'école
quel est l'autre proposition vous faites
par rapport à la critique que vous
faites alors il faut avoir
il faut avoir une éthique de
responsabilité autant qu'une éthique de
conviction et je pense que ça n'est pas
très honnête de jouer avec les émotions
sur un tel sujet nous avons besoin
d'avoir un peuple uni autour de son
école aujourd'hui il ya des peurs
certaines sont légitimes d'autres sont
cultivés par des personnes qui cherchent
à faire encore plus peur
je pense que ça quand on aime l'école de
la république on ne fait pas ça
aujourd'hui l'immense majorité des
mairies jouent le jeu en réalité et même
certains qui ont signé l'appel de ce
week-end en réalité vont ouvrir
c'était le cas de certains que j'ai vu
ce matin je ne les citerai pas dans le
morbihan par exemple j'en parlais avec
un député toutes les mairies toutes les
communes vont ouvrir sauf une
donc aujourd'hui le vrai travail de fond
il est en train de se réaliser
alors je sais bien que vous parlez vous
parlez de salons dorés moi je parlerais
de votre salon doré celui ont fait des
commentaires négatifs alors que des tas
de choses positives se passe sur le
terrain par des gens qui se retroussent
les manches des gens qui reconnaissent
la valeur de l'école de la république et
qui ne défendent pas l'école de la
république
quand les temps normaux l'instant il n'y
a pas de vagues et dès qu'il ya une
crise joue avec l'école de la république
en disant qu'elle n'est pas
indispensable aujourd'hui l'école de la
république est plus indispensable que
jamais ce serait beaucoup plus simple
pour moi de dire qu'on doit la fermer
jusqu'à jusqu au vaccin
eh bien je pense que non il faut couvrir
parce que j'ai des préoccupations
sociales
peut-être plus ancrée que les vôtres
merci monsieur le ministre
la parole est un monsieur jean-jacques
ferrara merci monsieur le président
monsieur le premier ministre
jeudi 30 avril c'est avec une certaine
stupeur et une profonde incompréhension
que les habitants les professionnels de
santé les représentants de l'état et les
élus de haute corse du lot et du cher
ont découvert que leur département était
classé en zone rouge
sur la première carte de la situation
épidémique national publié par le
gouvernement
peut-être que si le gouvernement avait
jugé utile de consulter préalablement
les acteurs locaux
un tel couac aurait pu être évité mais
il a été préféré semble-t-il d'agir
encore de manière verticale laissant le
directeur général de la santé dans son
intervention quotidienne du lendemain
rétablir la vérité d'un air gêné
contraint de naviguer entre explications
oiseuses et contre vérités
monsieur le premier ministre cette
énième dysfonctionnements de la
communication gouvernementale porte en
lui les germes d'une perte de confiance
dans votre parole ce n'est pas rien il
ya une semaine dans cet hémicycle vous
nous annonciez que l'adaptation réalité
du terrain en concertation avec les
autorités locales constituaient le
troisième principe de votre stratégie
nationale de déconfinement vous exposiez
également que les départements seraient
classés en trois critères la
concertation n'a pas eu lieu et les
critères n'ont pas été suivis dans ces
conditions quelle crédibilité accorder à
cette stratégie présentée ici même est
elle toujours d'actualité alors que les
français attendent avec impatience de
vous entendre
après demain sur les actions engagées
dès le 11 mai prochain pouvez-vous nous
garantir avoir pris les mesures
nécessaires auprès du ministère des
solidarités de la santé et de l'agencé
nationale de santé publique santé
publique france pour remédier
définitivement à ce type de
dysfonctionnement et faire en sorte que
soit respectée la parole du premier
ministre devant la représentation
nationale
merci chers collègues la parole est à
monsieur le premier ministre le
président mesdames et messieurs les
députés monsieur le député
j'ai indiqué c'est ce qui se passera que
la france et chaque département de notre
pays seraient classés soit en
départements versent au département
rouge en faisant la somme synthèse plus
exactement de trois séries de critères
non pas trois critères unique mais trois
séries de critères première série
critères le premier ensemble de critères
c'est c'est ceux qui mesurent la
prévalence des cas dans un département
donné c'est pas aussi simple que cela
peut paraître que de le mesurer
le premier critère qu'on a utilisée
était un indicatif de pression c'est à
dire que si j'ose dire
c'est à dire qu'on a regardé le nombre
de tests positifs plus exactement le
nombre de malades ducobu qui arrivait
dans un service d'urgence c'est un
indicateur intéressant mais si on
utilisait que cet indicateur là on
aurait quelque chose qui pourrait donner
des effets un peu absurde
prenons un exemple imaginer que on est
un petit service d'urgence et il ya des
départements dans lesquels il ya des
petits services d'urgence avec un nombre
étonnant mais ça peut arriver
deux cas de kevin qui arrivent là vous
auriez quelque chose qui serait un peu
aberrant
imaginez aussi que dans un certain
nombre de départements et pas dans tous
au procès et c'est arrivé à des tests
systématiques au moment où on regarde la
carte qu'on commence à construire
indicateur des personnels qui ont été le
plus exposés au virus par exemple ces
personnels qui travaillent dans les
ehpad travail dans les hôpitaux ce qui a
pu arriver on peut avoir un résultat là
aussi qui ne correspond pas
véritablement à la réalité
départementale et qui s'explique par la
photographie à un instant t
avec un seul critère pour éviter ces
effet aberrant
nous avons voulu justement faire
ensemble faire en sorte que ce critère
de prévalence soient élargies au maximum
avec le nombre de cas positifs
arrivé aux urgences avec le nombre de
cas qui remonte du réseau sentinelles
avec le nombre d'appels passés au samu
bref avec une batterie d'indicateurs qui
seront synthétisées dans une carte
qui mesurent la prévalence à un instant
t du virus un kart
la première carte qui a été élaboré et
qui classait en effet le haut-rhin et le
bas-rhin dans des couleurs auquel on ne
s'attendait pas qui classait la corse du
sud et la haute-corse dans des
départements dans des couleurs auquel on
ne s'attendait pas à été construite sur
un seul de ces sous-indicateurs nous
l'avons corriger au sens où nous prenons
de plus en plus d'indicateurs en compte
c'est ce qui explique que les
classements est ensuite évolué c'est la
première batterie d'indicateurs deuxième
batterie d'indicateurs
je leur dis parce qu'il faut essayer
d'être père vomi invités alors j'essaie
de le faire
deuxième batterie d'indicateurs un
indicateur qui est l'indicateur de
capacité d'accueil des services de
réanimation ils ont été soumis dans
certains territoires à une pression
absolument considérable il faut qu'ils
puissent avoir un peu de repos un peu de
répit et il serait inenvisageable de
faire comme si on pouvait réouvrir
facilement dans des départements où la
pression était considérable et où la
capacité d'accueil des services de
réanimation n'est pas remonté cet
indicateur nous l'analysons de façon
régionales pourquoi pourrait contester
on peut dire maintenant façon
départemental on le fait de façon
régionales parce que ce qu'on a observé
c'est que lorsque on était en phase de
l'épidémie
c'étaient les capacités d'accueil de
l'ensemble des hôpitaux d'une région qui
étaient mobilisés pour faire face à une
situation de crise dans un département
vous savez parfaitement comme moi
monsieur le député que dans le haut rhin
dans le haut rhin
quand l'hôpital de mulhouse a été
confrontée à cette vague terrible il y a
eu et c'est tant mieux à mulhouse et à
colmar des transferts massifs vers
strasbourg vers nancy et que cette
l'ensemble du système hospitalier
régional est d'ailleurs quelques jours
après pendant quelques semaines
l'ensemble du système national qui a
permis à l'hôpital de mulhouse de tenir
et donc nous apprécions cette
disponibilité des services de
réanimation à l'échelle régionale
deuxième batterie de critères 3e
batterie de critères
il est important il est assez peu
expliqué aujourd'hui mais il est très
important c'est la capacité
opérationnelle dans chaque département a
remonté les chaînes de contamination et
à pouvoir les casser ça veut dire la
disponibilité des tests c'est un facteur
matériel extrêmement important ça veut
dire aussi est en vérité surtout la
capacité des équipes à mobiliser ceux
qui doivent bénéficier des tests à aller
effectivement faire en sorte de tester
ceux qui en ont besoin et pour ça il
faut que les brigades que j'ai évoquées
juge possible terme est parfait en
vérité disons les équipes les équipes
qui seront constitués autour des
médecins libéraux b autour des
personnels de l'assurance maladie sous
la responsabilité des préfets soient
capables immédiatement de remonter
l'ensemble des chaînes de contamination
c'est l'indicateur qui est important si
on veut savoir la capacité qu'on a à
maîtriser l'épidémie et c3 creed ces
trois séries de critères ensemble qui
sont de nature différente combinés nous
donne la capacité à mesurer la réalité
dans chaque département voilà les trois
critères
et voilà pourquoi les cartes qui sont
parus le premier jour de ces cartes ont
pu être par la suite modifié la vérité
c'est qu'elles le seront au fur et à
mesure et que tous les jours nous
publierons ses cartes en fonction de
l'évolution de ses indicateurs
merci monsieur le premier ministre la
parole est à madame nadia a pas reçu les
moins chers collègues
monsieur le premier ministre j'ai bien
compris les critères je voulais
simplement pointer du doigt cette
manière ce dysfonctionnement avec avec
cette non concertation préalable avant
la publication de la carte des préfets
et des directeurs des agences régionales
de santé
c'est insupportable et ça va à
l'encontre de votre volonté que vous
nous avons a lancé dans l'hémicycle la
semaine dernière
la parole est cette fois bel et bien à
madame nadia et merci merci monsieur le
président ma question s'adresse à
monsieur julien de l'hormadi de
normandie pardon mise de la ville et du
logement et j'associe ma collectif cap
arc à cette question monsieur le
ministre nous avons tous été ému par ces
images insupportables de toutes ces
files d'attentes de distribution des
aides alimentaires
nombreux sont les élus qui comme nous
craignaient craignait que ces périodes
amplifie davantage les inégalités qui
existent particulièrement dans les
quartiers prioritaires de la ville où
vivent ces mères célibataires ces
retraités aux minima sociaux ou encore
ces demandeurs d'emploi on y retrouve
aussi c'est au héros du quotidien
applaudi tous les soirs à 20h
ils sont être soignants livreur
auxiliaire de vie
caissier mécanicien brancardier ou
encore enseignants tous les jours ils
font en sorte que la vie continue
de retour chez eux ils côtoient ceux qui
restent confinées pour participer à
l'effort national de lutte contre
l'épidémie dans ses tours hlm parfois
dans la souffrance
confinés dans des logements qui
deviennent de plus en plus petit au fil
au fur et à mesure que le temps passe
parfois même dans une insalubrité
insupportable à laquelle s'ajoute une
insécurité alimentaire une détresse
silencieuse parce qu'ils ne savent pas
comment assurer l'école à la maison
faute de matériel numérique parce qu'ils
n'ont pas les moyens financiers
d'assurer les trois repas par jour pour
leur enfant et que dire alors de ceux
qui n'ont même pas de toi nous le
savions nous savions à l'annonce du
confinement que ceux qui souffraient
allait souffrir davantage
monsieur le ministre vous étiez de ceux
qui savaient très vite vous avez pris
des décisions pour soutenir les
associations qui font un travail
formidable avec des bénévoles qui ne
ménagent ni leur temps ni leurs efforts
l'ensemble du gouvernement a fait en
sorte d'apporter des réponses fortes
là où il n'y en a pas alors monsieur le
ministre
quelles décisions ont été prises pour
soulager ses souffrances apaiser cette
détresse ou compensées ou compenser ces
inégalités dans le milieu scolaire pour
ne laisser
personne personne au bord de la route
merci merci chers collègues la parole
est à monsieur julien de normandie
ministre chargé de la ville et du
logement
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés madame la députée
nadia et vous évoquez cette détresse
silencieuse vous avez raison la détresse
le plus souvent il n'a pas de
conversation
elle laisse elle atteint sa dignité et
sa dignité parfois elle est atteinte
dans nos quartiers
un certain nombre de quartiers de france
et cela est d'autant plus insupportable
que la france qui a continué à
travailler pour les autres
souvent c'est aussi la france de ces
quartiers celle qui a continué à
travailler dans les supermarchés les
hôpitaux ou dans des entreprises et donc
je veux moi aussi leur rendre hommage
le rendre hommage bien loin d'un certain
nombre de clichés souvent véhiculés sans
en rien minimiser les difficultés
auxquelles nous sommes confrontés parce
que oui il y a des difficultés
et cette difficulté les parfois d'ordre
alimentaire
nous avons vu de plus en plus de
familles de familles précaires de
familles modestes demander des aides
alimentaires
face à ça nous avons enclenché un plan
d'urgence d'aidé alimentaire avec
christelle du boss et olivier ferrand 50
millions d'euros pour accompagner les
associations ou des livres et des
chèques services
mais il ya également beaucoup de
familles modestes de famille pour lequel
les enfants allaient à la cantine avant
et qui aujourd'hui n'ont plus accès à
cette cantine qui coûtent souvent très
peu cher et donc face à ça nous avons
décidé le premier ministre a mis en
place cette aide sociale exceptionnelle
qui sera versée sans aucune démarche à
toutes les familles aux appels au rsa à
l'oeil c'est ce à partir du 15 mai et au
delà de cette urgence sociale il y a
également l'urgence éducative c'est ce
que nous avons fait avec jean michel
blanquer pour lutter contre toutes
celles et ceux qui sont trop éloignés de
l'école souvent par défaut d'accès au
numérique ce sujet qui était très cher à
votre ancienne collègue corinne erhel
qui est décédé il ya trois ans jour pour
jour aujourd'hui qui s'était battu pour
cela et donc nous avons mis en place un
fonds de 10 millions
d'euros pour aider ces familles à avoir
accès au numérique
l'urgence année social et éducatif et
c'est ce pourquoi nous nous battons avec
vous et je vous en remercie
merci monsieur le ministre la parole est
à monsieur le président philippe vigier
oui merci monsieur le président monsieur
le premier ministre lors de votre
déclaration sur déconfinement vous avez
parlé de la différenciation territoriale
et vous avez appelé à faire confiance au
génie local et tiens à vous dire que
c'est pas ce qui se passe aujourd'hui
sur le terrain c'est parce qu'il se
passe avec les écoles protocole sa
litière de 60 pages souvent
inapplicables génère de leurs angoisses
la communauté éducative chez les parents
et pas ce qui se passe sur les
transports notamment les transports
scolaires et si on appliquait directives
et des enfants qu'on ne peut pas
transporter pour les ehpad c'est visite
tant attendue sont réservées quasiment
tout le temps à l'extérieur ça c'est
dommage qu'on n'ait pas pu être
consultés et j'ajoute que c'est le
premier disque devra réussir le 2 juin
parce que le 2 juin il y aura c'est pas
un cadre homogène qu'il faudra appliquer
pour les bars pour les restaurants pour
les sites touristiques pour les sites
culturels
il faudra justement l'a piqué territoire
par territoire face à ce virus avec
lesquels nous devons apprendre à vivre
et pour longtemps n'avons pas besoin des
circulaires fleuve mais nous avons
besoin de cadrage concis très souvent
les élus locaux ont parfois le sentiment
que les services de l'état ne
considèrent pas comme des partenaires
mais comme des exécutants et qui se
dépose sur eux la lutte contre la crise
sanitaire doit être organisée par bassin
dur permettant aux territoires dû faire
du cousu main en leur donnant une vraie
capacité de décision sur le calendrier
sur le périmètre sur les modalités de
déconfinement ils assureront leurs
responsabilités en tout cas je fais
partie de ce monsieur le premier
ministre qui n'envisage pas de me
défausser
alors êtes vous prêt à donner des vraies
marges de manoeuvre territoires qui sont
en première ligne avec cette crise
sanitaire cette crise économique et qui
seront les acteurs essentiels de la
transformation économique du pays et du
rebond tant attendue du pays je vous
remercie
merci monsieur le président la parole
est à monsieur le premier ministre les
députés j'ai indiqué monsieur le
président vigik
nous ne pourrions trouver des solutions
pratiques qu en faisant confiance aux
acteurs de terrain dans le respect de la
doctrine sanitaires sur le président si
nous ne formulons pas de doctrine
sanitaire croyez moi les critiques
seraient au moins égale à celle que nous
entendons aujourd'hui parce qu'elle
aurait été fixée trop strictement donc
nous avons fixé une doctrine sanitaire
nous avons essayé de dire et de répondre
aux questions qui se posent le plus
souvent et nous avons dit j'ai dit au
préfet j'ai dit aux responsables de
l'éducation nationale les ministres
peuvent en témoigner qu'il convenait de
s'accorder localement sur les mesures
les plus adaptées correspondant à
l'esprit dans lesquels nous avions
indiqué qu'il fallait travailler mais
reconnaissait avec moi que dans la
question que vous posez il ya des
aspects qui sont intéressants vous me
dites dans les ehpad
il n'y aurait qu'une solution univoque
mais monsieur le président vigier c'est
pas le gouvernement qui détermine
comment s'organisent partout dans les
ehpad les rencontres que nous avons
autorisé ce sont les directeurs d'ehpad
qui prennent leur responsabilité en
disant ça c'est possible ça n'est pas
possible parfois ils préfèrent que les
rues que les réunions aient lieu à
l'extérieur parce que ça leur paraît
limiter les risques et moi je les
entends faire confiance aux acteurs
c'est aussi leur dire que quand ils
prennent ces décisions
il ne se trompe pas alors évidemment il
ya des directives nal d'ailleurs parfois
il les demandes même mais vous ne pouvez
pas je crois pas qu'on puisse dire que
c'est le gouvernement qui est
responsable de dire de donner des
contraintes trop féroce aux directeurs
d'ehpad quel que soit d'ailleurs les
très nombreux statuts de ces ehpad pour
dire comment est ce que devraient avoir
lieu les rencontres
vraiment on n'a pas envoyé le protocole
dix ans ça doit se passer comme s'y est
pas comme ça au contraire on a dit c'est
important qu'il y ait des visites et
c'est important qu'elle soit très
encadrée pour éviter un risque
considérable bon on peut pas dire autre
chose monsieur le président vigier et
donc les directeurs d'ehpad prennent
leur responsabilité parfois on trouve
qu'ils vont trop loin parfois on trouve
qu'ils vont pas assez loin parfois en
tant qu' et c'est là qu'à une
appréciation qui est d'ailleurs délicate
mais je crois que vous comme moi on peut
leur faire confiance pour trouver les
bonnes solutions
ils ont montré dans
la quasi totalité des cas dans la
totalité des cas le souci qui était le
leur de faire en sorte de faire face à
une situation redoutablement complexe
avec des personnes qui sont évidemment
très fragile je crois qu'on peut leur
reconnaître la capacité d'adaptation et
d'interprétation et que parfois si ils
prennent trop de mesures pour garantir
la sécurité
il faut se dire qu'ils le font parce
qu'ils ont traversé un moment très
difficile avec des personnels très
fragile et que même si vous pensez ou si
certains pensent qu'on pourra aller un
peu plus vite
je crois qu'on peut aussi de bonne foi
se dire qu'ils n'ont pas complètement
tort
en étant encore plus prudent que ce que
peut-être ils pourraient ils pourraient
être sur la capacité locale à se mettre
d'accord
je maintiens ce que nous avons dit bien
sûr il ya des éléments de doctrine qui
ont été formulées s'agissant de la
reprise des écoles et bien sûr il ya des
endroits où les maires ou les directeurs
d'école trouve ça très difficile mais
reconnaissez avec moi qu'il ya
énormément d'endroits où les adjoints au
maire en charge les directeurs d'école
les fédérations de parents d'élèves et
c'est de trouver le bon système
si je devais résumer tout ça je dis ne
disons pas que cette reprise ne doit
avoir lieu nulle part parce qu'elle
serait seulement possible quelque part
il est possible dans beaucoup d'endroits
de trouver les bonnes solutions
et quand elles seront trouvées il y aura
des retours à l'école et chaque retour à
l'école sera une bonne nouvelle et
peut-être dans des endroits ce sera un
peu plus difficile et peut-être que dans
certains endroits durera un peu plus
angoisses et peut-être même et je le dis
très prudemment parce que je pense que
ce sera infiniment
résiduelles peut-être même parfois un
peu d'angoissé qui déboucherait presque
sûr de la mauvaise vente
je ne peux pas exclure que parfois ça
arrive mais à la fin de la fin non ce ne
sera pas la majorité des cas ce sera à
l'infini minorité des cas mais je pense
mais je pense que partout on arrivera à
trouver la solution pour rouvrir les
écoles et que chaque retour à l'école
sera une bonne nouvelle pour les enfants
concernés et pour notre pays merci
monsieur le premier ministre à madame
agnès style
merci monsieur le président ma question
concerne l'information et s'adresse à
monsieur le premier ministre monsieur le
premier ministre le 3 mai avant-hier
était la journée mondiale de la liberté
de la presse et il est bon de rappeler
que la presse est libre à l'égard du
pouvoir
alors oui monsieur le premier ministre
la presse n'est pas seulement un
véhicule d'information ou d'opinion
c'est un pouvoir et qui apprécient le
pouvoir qui s'opposent aux siens
question de rapport de force nous disait
françois giroux en 81 alors vous avez
créé le site gouvernemental qui à défaut
de censurer new tree l'information je
rappelle d'ailleurs que madame la
secrétaire d'état avait dit j'assume de
mentir ceux qui a le mérite d'être très
clair pardon pour le lapsus au moins
c'est clair concernant l'exactitude et
la vérité exit les uns fox et
l'effet que news seul le monde
libération france tv info et 20 minutes
ont les faveurs de votre gouvernement
les autres apprécieront avouez que ce
gouvernement a l'art de poser quand ils
prônent exactement le contraire les
articles cités sur votre site qui
prônait nous dit là juste bonne et vraie
parole évite les sujets qui fâchent
tandis que ceux ayant pris la défense du
gouvernement semble abondamment relayée
voyez-vous ce qui ce qui est gênant
lorsque j'étais enfant les anciens
parlait de ceux qui habitaient de
l'autre côté du mur de berlin il les
appelait d'ailleurs les roues ce qu'on
ne comprend pas lorsqu'on est enfant
mais il parlait et il disait aussi ceci
je cite il disait derrière ce mur il y a
des paroles qui ne vont que dans un sens
et ça c'est pas honnête aussi monsieur
le premier ministre
est ce que votre gouvernement prétend
détenir la vérité
via son site d'informations je vous
remercie
merci chers collègues la parole et à
monsieur marc fesneau ministre chargé
des relations avec le parlement
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés madame la députée
tinne je vais essayer de répondre à
votre question on est important deux
angles le premier la liberté de la
presse est d'ailleurs un droit
constitutionnel que nous respectons et
nous sommes ici tous attachés à la
liberté de la presse
ça nécessite d'ailleurs qu'on soit
capable les uns les autres d'avoir des
contradictions d'avoir des controverses
ça fait partie aussi la liberté de la
liberté politique et de la liberté
démocratique et je suis sûr que vous y
êtes aussi tout à fait à tâcher vous
voyez aussi qu'on a un sujet mais qui ne
relève pas du sujet la liberté de la
presse c'est le fait que les réseaux
sociaux sont de puissants outils parfois
et c'est pas une cenne pas une question
de la liberté de la presse sont de
puissants outils pour faire circuler des
informations qui en quelques minutes
deviendrez vérité parce qu'elles ont
cent mille dix mille ou un million de
lacs ou de retweet et c'est à ça donc il
faut faire attention parce que dans un
moment où au fond l'ensemble des
autorités de ce qu'elle représente les
autorités scientifiques les autorités
politiques les autorités juridiques ou à
chaque fois quelqu'un vient chercher du
complot du complot
this mot travers de ces outils qui sont
des outils formidables mais qui peuvent
révéler aussi leur côté sombre si vous
avez vous avez raison ça fait partie de
la diversité de la presse c'est pour ça
que je suis attaché monsieur jumelles
aussi à l'humanité à toute la diversité
de la presse parce que il y aurait que
l'humanité on s'ennuierait et
reconnaissons le est donc il faut à peu
tous dans la diversité de l'opinion et
donc madame la députée distinguons les
choses le gouvernement est attaché à la
liberté la presse reconnaissons que nous
ne sommes pas comment dirais-je
la presse n'est pas avare de compliments
mais n'est pas avoir aussi de critiquer
c'est très bien ainsi parce que c'est ça
la démocratie
mais soyons vigilants aussi sur des
outils qui parfois n'informe pas m'aider
à former qui pose de graves questions
dans la démocratie pour un gouvernement
mais pour l'ensemble des responsables
politiques que nous sommes je vous
remercie
merci monsieur le ministre la parole est
un monsieur stéphane viry merci merci
monsieur le président le sujet le sujet
des masques a déjà été évoquée à juste
titre parce que c'est le péché originel
de cette crise épidémique est monsieur
près ministres où je vais à mon tour vos
ministres vous interroger sur l'axé ou
masques équipements de première
nécessité pour l'ensemble de nos
compatriotes
je ne reviendrai pas une surprime in his
mesdames et messieurs gouvernement sur
votre gestion de crise en matière de
masques hasardeuse et déroutante viendra
le temps des conclusions vous l'avais
dit il ya un instant monsieur
prémunissent mais sachez que
l'incrédulité et le désarroi règne dans
les territoires tant les français sont
las des annonces contradictoires de
votre gouvernement
j'écoutais les réponses précédentes aux
questions sur les masques à ce jour à ce
jour beaucoup de professionnels de la
santé manquent encore de masques de
protection
la vérité c'est que l'état n'arrive pas
à leur fournir des masques à l'aube d'un
déconfinement qui suscite une habitante
grandissantes quant à sa date nous
découvrons que la grande distribution la
grande distribution est parvenu à
constituer des stocks très importants de
masques et ceux qui le dira a doublé
l'état comment notre france comment
l'état est il devenu si impuissants au
point d'être supplantés dancy propres
sion par les enseignes de supermarchés
pourquoi surtout avez vous été incapable
de présenter ces masques pour les
distribuer en priorité aux professions
médicales qui en ont tant besoin
nous apprenons aujourd'hui que le
ministère de la santé a bien dissuader
les officines et pharmacie de vendre des
masques depuis le 23 mars
c'est insupportable et incompréhensible
par ailleurs et j'en terminerai comment
pouvez-vous indiquer qu'il y aura je
cite monsieur premier ministre assez de
masques pour faire face aux besoins à
partir du 11 mai alors que les
orthophonistes les kinésithérapeutes les
orthoptistes par exemple peine à se
procurer de tels équipements et que la
majorité des français n'ont pas pu à ce
jour s'en procurer outre le choc
sanitaires et économiques ne provoquait
pas à chocques démocratique répondait
aux attentes des français
peg la parole à monsieur adrien taquet
secrétaire d'état auprès du ministre des
solidarités de la santé monsieur le
député il ya effectivement dans notre
démocratie une seconde chambre le sénat
se trouve actuellement le ministre de la
santé
il y en a 3 c'est vrai monsieur le
ministre vous avez raison merci monsieur
le président mesdames et messieurs les
députés monsieur le député avant de vous
happe le conseil économique social et
environnemental
alors si vous me permettez de répondre
de façon très précise
écoutez monsieur je pense dans des
sujets suffisamment sérieux pour une
partie dans des polémiques inutiles
monsieur le député pour répondre très
précisément à la question qui est la
vôtre vous rappeler d'une part que nous
avons ces deux derniers mois distribué
près de 2 300 millions pardon de masques
aux professionnels de santé ce sont 45
millions de masques chaque semaine qui
sont distribués aux professionnels de
santé ça sera 100 millions demain vous
comprenez bien qu'en phase de sortie le
confinement
la stratégie de répartition des masques
sanitaires a vocation à évoluer je vais
vous donner un certain nombre de de
précisions sur les différentes
professions vous avez évoqué à partir du
11 mai dès le 11 mai 14 mars que par
semaine seront délivrés sur ordonnance
pour les malades du cobp il dit
neuf ainsi que pour les personnes qui
auront été en contact sur indication de
l'assurance maladie pour les personnes à
haut risque médical dix masques par
semaine pourront leur être attribué ce
notamment via des officines n'y a pas de
raison d'opposer la grande distribution
aux officines l'état aux collectivités
locales l'état aux entreprises
le premier ministre l'a bien dit pour
assurer à l'ensemble de nos concitoyens
le fait de pouvoir posséder des masques
au 11 mai nous devons tous être unis
pour les soignants les professionnels de
santé
nous allons relever pour les soignants
libéraux les médecins les dentistes les
infirmiers à 24 masques par semaine je
parle bien des masques chirurgicaux et
parfois des ffp2 pour les autres
professions 18 masques par semaine ça
concerne les pharmaciens les
kinésithérapeutes les sages-femmes pour
les aident les salariés de l'aide à
domicile ce seront quinze masques par
semaine et 12 matches par semaine pour
les autres professions de santé
je parle je pense d'eux aux opticiens ou
aux psychologues
enfin les établissements sociaux et
médico sociaux verront leurs stocks
augmenter de 50 de près de 50%
vous le voyez monsieur mes films sur les
spéciales de sauter seront dotés aux
onze mêmes
merci monsieur le ministre et comme vous
le savez les parlementaires estiment que
le conseil économique et social
vénérable est très respectable
institution comme son nom l'indiqué est
un conseil n'ont pas une chambre mais
pas de querelles à dormir debout au
sujet des chambres ce sera mieux
la parole la parole est maintenant un
madame marietta karamanli vous avez la
parole monsieur le président bonjour à
tous ma question s'adresse à aux pros
ministre de la santé et des solidarités
et c'est sur la question des masques
justement le dcau finement va nécessiter
l'utilisation pendant des longues
périodes longues semaines de masques de
protection dont le port est recommandée
elle sera rendue obligatoire dans les
lieux où les règles de dissociation
sociale ne peuvent être systématiquement
appliquée comme dans le death transports
en commun la grande distribution a en
vend déjà avec des interrogations sur
des stocks constitués en soit cela
pourrait être donc une bonne nouvelle
pendant des semaines des professionnels
de santé et tous ceux en contact avec le
public pendant le confinement en avait
tant cherché mais les inquiétudes sont
fortes
le site d'afnor recommande de chant de
changer de masque trois fois par jour au
moins toutes les trois quatre heures
pour une personne travaillant à
l'extérieur
rapporté au un prix standard de 30 à 50
centimes d'euros 3,3 changement
reviendrait à faire supporter une
dépense de 24 à 30 euros par personne au
travail par mois pour les masquer un
tissu vendus qui auraient une durée
d'utilisation optimale de 30 minutes et
pourrait être l'avait de 10 à 20 fois la
dépense pourrait être de 10 à 15 euros
par personne et par mois
si vos enfants vont à l'école et votre
conjoint travaille
vous multipliez les sommes il est
impératif donc que quel que soit le
masque l'accès gratuit ou aider en soit
garanti aux plus modestes fragile par
pour la relance entre par leur santé les
salariés et les professionnels donc ma
question est simple comment le
concitoyen faut reconnaître les masques
efficace est donc certifié qui va
contrôler la qualité de ces de se porter
quelles aides vont être donnés aux plus
modestes et aux plus fragiles
quelle mesure donc monsieur le ministre
en visite à je vais vous pour garantir
l'accès aux masques les moins chers ou
gratuits et les plus efficaces
tous nos concitoyens j'aimerais merci
merci chers collègues la parole est à
madame agnès tenir une ag secrétaire
d'état auprès du ministre de l'économie
et des finances
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés
madame la députée karamanli merci de
poser cette question parce qu'elle pose
beaucoup de questions que se pose
effectivement les français d'abord dans
quels cas je dois payer mon masque et
dans quel cas il me sera fournie par
d'autres circuits le premier ministre
l'a indiqué un instant lorsque vous
envoyez votre enfant à l'école et qu'il
doit pas porter de manière obligatoire
un masque alors jusqu'à la fin de
l'année scolaire
ce masque lui sera fourni et nous sommes
en train d'acheminer des masques en
taille adulte et en taille enfants dans
les écoles
la deuxième chose c'est lorsque vous
reprenez le travail lorsque vous
reprenez le travail il y à des
protocoles qui sont de reprise du
travail qui doivent être discutés
notamment avec les organisations
syndicales avec les représentants du
personnel et qui prévoit toutes les
mesures de dispensation social dans ce
cas lorsqu'il n'est pas possible de
ménager cette distanciation sociale il
est de la responsabilité de l'employeur
d'équiper ses salariés ses opérateurs
avec des masques c'est ce que nous
faisons dans notre responsabilité
employeur en tant qu'etat ce ce que font
aujourd'hui les employeurs et nous les
accompagnons pour équiper l'ensemble de
leurs salariés lorsqu'ils ne peuvent pas
respecter la distanciation social de
masques s'agissant maintenant d autres
circonstances de la vie
je crois que mes collègues de la santé
et le premier ministre ont été très
clair tout ce qui concerne les
personnels soignants et les malades et
pris en charge par santé publique france
selon des protocoles très clair dans une
filière qui est sanctuarisé et
quitterait qui passe par les pharmaciens
et là encore c'est un système de
gratuité qui est prévu enfin s'agissant
du grand public nous avons mis en place
une filière de masques textile nous
avons un apport complémentaire de
masques chirurgicaux avec des
filtrations garantie et l'ensemble des
éléments de réassurance sont sur le site
du ministère de l'économie et la
direction générale de la même la
consommation répression des fraudes sera
qui les contrôlent merci madame la
ministre
la parole est un monsieur jean-pierre
vizier mais merci monsieur le président
monsieur le premier ministre vous avez
retenu notre proposition d'un
déconfinement par département et nous
vous en remercions
cette approche par territoire est
essentielle en effet il serait
incompréhensible d'imposer aux
départements moins touchés par le
comique 19 les mêmes contraintes que
dans les départements les plus atteints
pour ce faire une carte fiable des
territoires à risque doit être élaboré
j'espère donc que vous pourrez lever les
inquiétudes exposé sur les imprécisions
de votre carte comme pour mon
département de la haute loire par
exemple mais surtout cette logique soupe
d'adaptation par territoire ne peut se
limiter à la seule réouverture des parcs
et jardins ou des collèges
il faut aller plus loin et poussé
jusqu'au bout la logique d'un
déconfinement par département notamment
pour la reprise des cultes mais surtout
au niveau économique
s'il est impératif de relancer plus
fortement et plus rapidement la reprise
économique au niveau national
nous souhaitons une accélération de la
reprise de l'activité avec une
réouverture dès le 11 mai des cafés et
des restaurants mais aussi des activités
touristiques dans les départements
classés en vert cela permettra de sauver
bon nombre d'acteurs économiques ces
réouvertures se ferait bien sûr dans des
conditions très encadrées en respectant
des règles sanitaires très strictes
monsieur le premier ministre vous vous
dites favorables une gestion
décentralisée du déconfinement alors
pourquoi ne pas accélérer la reprise
économique dans les départements qui
seront classés en vert le 7 mai prochain
je vous remercie merci chers collègues
la parole est à madame la secrétaire
d'état auprès du ministre des
solidarités de la santé vaincre et steve
du buzz merci monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les députés
vous avez en effet monsieur le député
parler d'une cartographie cette
cartographie avait été annoncée par le
premier ministre allait sorti dès la
semaine prochaine
à ce jour elle compte trois couleurs
trois couleurs qui ne sont pas une
mauvaise note au département mais qui
sont bien des indicateurs et des
indicateurs basés sur trois éléments
dont a rappelé le premier ministre
indicateurs fiables qui permettent de
donner une couleur au département et à
compter du 7 mai il y aura bien que deux
couleurs c'est rouge et vert ils se sont
bien des indicateurs qu'il s'agisse de
la pression et du nombre de patients
envoyés aux urgences qu'il s'agisse bien
du système de santé ou encore ce
troisième indicateur qui interviendra à
partir du 7 mai cette capacité de tests
par département
et par l'ensemble des acteurs se sont
bien passées un indicateur que nous
prenons en compte cette cartographie
mais nous devons avoir un cadre national
sur la question de déconfinement et ce
dès confinement a été présenté par le
premier ministre ici puis au sénat hier
après midi avec différentes échelles on
est sept premières échelon est lancé aux
pro à partir du 11 mai jusqu'à fin mai
sur lequel il y aura une deuxième en
fonction des résultats de cette première
marche une deuxième évaluation de cette
pub déconfinement et donc c'est bien
progressivement que nous prenons en
compte toutes les situations toutes les
situations avec un cadre national parce
que nous devons être prudents nous
devons être aussi attentif à notre
système de santé à notre système aussi
éventuelle d'une seconde vague
d'épidémie c'est face à tout cela que
nous devons faire face mais sachez que
toute la question de l'économie de ce
qu'il s'agisse des commerces de
proximité des restaurants ou des cafés
c'est bien travaillé en lien avec les
ministères de l'économie et du bien et
notre objectif est bien de réouvrir mais
il faut ré ouvrir une bonne condition et
surtout assurer la sécurité de nos
concitoyens qu'ils soient salariés
qu'ils soient entrepreneurs ou qu'ils
puissent être client je vous remercie
merci madame la ministre la parole est
un monsieur hubert wulfranc pigeât
pardon il ya plusieurs façons de vous le
dire ça a été exprimée sur ses dents moi
je vais je vais vous le faire façon
colère je vous faire façon colère parce
que les masques pour nous il faut que ce
soit gratuit
on va pas bricoler il faut que ce soit
gratuit et ce pour les quelques mois qui
viennent pour l'équipage tout le micro
parce que le cul colère pour les
quelques mois qui viennent qui sont
décisifs effectivement non seulement
pour la santé des français mais aussi
pour leur portefeuille alors de fait
étant donné que vous n'êtes pas un
gouvernement qui loin de là prône une
économie administrée
vous n'avez pas réquisitionné et c'est
donc bel et bien le secteur marchand qui
va assurer de manière privilégiée
l'avs la distribution de ces masques ça
veut dire une guerre des prix
une inégalité d'accès et un coup de
toute façon non négligeable pour les
familles
et ce sont ces grands groupes de la
distribution qui sortent pile poil une
semaine avant le déconfinement des
stocks très conséquents dont nous
n'avons aucune garantie
madame la ministre oui vous avez voulu y
répondre mais aucune garantie voyons
voyons les inspections du travail qui
elle est qu'elle est comment ils peuvent
travailler sur déjà des contentieux du
reiki ad hoc dans les entreprises on n'a
aucune garantie de contrôle des prix ne
serait-ce qu à prix coûtant pour la
vente de ses basques donc qu'est-ce que
vous répondez à ces mères comme celui de
saint-etienne du rouvray comme celui de
grenoble et mais également qu'ils vous
disent bas laissez-nous réquisitionné
auprès de nos grandes surfaces
les stocks de masques qui sont prêtes
mises en vente ont les achètera surnom
deniers municipaux pour les ventiler à
tous je dis bien à tous nos administrés
qu'est ce que vous leur répondez merci
chers collègues la parole est à madame
agnès pannier rina chez secrétaire
d'état auprès du ministre de l'économie
et des finances
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés monsieur le député
wulfranc comme vous nous avons à coeur
de faire en sorte que les français les
plus précaires les plus démunis est un
accès aisé aux masques et c'est pour
cette raison que l'état s'est organisée
non seulement pour apporter à l'ensemble
des soignants et aux personnes qui pour
des raisons sanitaires ont besoin des
masques un circuit au travers des
pharmacies et que le ministre de la
santé olivier vers ans a annoncé la mise
à disposition de l'ensemble du système
sanitaire de 100 millions de masques
chaque semaine c'est qui est une
multiplication par deux et demi du
nombre de masques disponibles pour ces
personnes mais également nous avons
réservé et nous avons acheté 5 millions
de masques réutilisables plus de 20 fois
soit l'équivalent de 105 millions de
masques à usage unique spécifiquement
pour les personnes précaires ils seront
livrés chaque semaine aux préfets et
distribué au maire donc je crois que ça
répond à votre première question
deuxième question s'agissant à partir de
la semaine du 11 mai monsieur jumelles
et juste chaque semaine à partir de la
semaine du 11 mai pour répondre à votre
deuxième question au delà du fait que
les gens pourront s'équiper dans les
écoles puisque les enfants qui devront
obligatoirement porter les masses le
verrons fournir jusqu'à la fin d'année
scolaire et les employeurs qui ne sont
pas capables d'assurer la distanciation
social dans les entreprises devront
également équipée en masques leurs
salariés pour les autres usages je veux
juste rappeler un petit point la grande
distribution qui travaillent à sourcer
des masques les entreprises
industrielles qui sont en train de
fabriquer des masques et les artisans
qui fabrique également des masques sont
lents des normes particulièrement
exigeante puisque les industriels
doivent justifier d'un test devant le
laboratoire de la vga sont en train de
distribuer ces masques à quasi prix
coûtant alors je crois monsieur que nous
devons nous réjouir d'avoir plutôt une
abondance de masques dans les semaines
qui viennent que de regretter
la situation que nous avons traversée
merci madame la ministre la parole est
un monsieur sébastien leclerc merci
monsieur le président monsieur le
premier ministre le 16 mars la fermeture
des établissements scolaires a été une
décision relativement facile à mettre en
oeuvre
il a fallu repenser les modalités de
l'enseignement à distance et le plus
souvent sous forme dématérialisée avec
une implication très forte de nos
enseignants que nous voulons ici saluer
avec l'aide de nombreuses collectivités
qui ont prêté des ordinateurs des
tablettes numériques aux familles ne
disposant pas la continuité pédagogique
et depuis assuré et puis il ya cette
décision d'un retour à l'école le 11 mai
et rouvrir une école en période
d'épidémie
c'est beaucoup plus compliqué que de la
fermer et d'organiser les enseignements
autrement basé sur le volontariat des
familles ce retour à l'école ne
permettra pas de raccrocher tout les
décrocheurs qui s'en sont éloignés
les maires sont en première ligne pour
repenser cet accueil à l'école
fonctionnement de la garderie remise en
route de la cantine travaux en urgence
pour créer des points d'eau pour
aménager des sanitaires
le tout souvent avec une partie du
personnel municipal qui n'a pas pu
reprendre son poste
la situation actuelle génère beaucoup de
confusion et dans le guen chez les
parents les enseignants eux mêmes nous
disent que s'ils arrivent à envisager le
retour de trois niveaux le 12 mai il ne
voit pas comment un retour simultanée
des huit niveaux pourra se faire le 25
mai monsieur le premier ministre
j'ai trois questions précises à vous
poser premièrement pouvez vous assurer à
chaque enseignant qu'il sera doté en
masque fournis par sa direction
académique dès le 11 mai deuxièmement
allez vous accepter les amendements au
projet de loi qui est discuté cette
semaine afin de clarifier de dégager
totalement la responsabilité pénale des
maires par rapport à la décision de
rouvrir les écoles
troisièmement comment envisagez-vous le
déroulement de l'année scolaire 2020
merci monsieur le député la parole à
monsieur jean michel blanquer ministre
de l'éducation nationale et de la
jeunesse
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés monsieur le député
sébastien leclerc je vais évidemment
répondre à votre question vous avez
commencé votre propos en disant que
l'entrée dans le confinement avait été
facile je vous renvoie à nos débats il
ya deux mois et à tout ce qui s'est dit
à ce moment là ce n'était pas si facile
que cela
et il y avait beaucoup de doute beaucoup
de scepticisme sur la capacité
d'adaptation de l'éducation nationale et
vous-même deux mois après vous jugez que
ça a été réussi et je vous en remercie
parce qu'en effet l'engagement des
professeurs a permis cela et toute
l'organisation de l'éducation nationale
et j'espère que dans deux mois vous
saluer la façon dont le déconfinement
s'est passé peut-être vous aurez oublié
certaines des critiques un peu acerbe et
bien je vais vous dire rien n'est facile
dans ce que nous avons à faire et si
c'était facile ça se saurait nous avons
des contacts avec des ministres de toute
l'europe avec des pays du monde entier
avec la francophonie aussi tous les pays
sont évidemment confrontés à cette
difficulté est aujourd'hui n'importe qui
peut souligner les difficultés
c'est un sport finalement assez facile
le vrai sujet c'est le rapport avantages
inconvénients de chacune des décisions
que nous prenons et bien c'est à cette
aune que je vais répondre à votre
question
premièrement sur les masques la réponse
est oui les masques sont fournis nous
avons fait tout un travail logistique
depuis plusieurs semaines pour les
obtenir et pour les distribuer et de
toute façon une école n'ouvrira pas si
elle n'a pas les masques le moment venu
et donc elle les aurons dès le 11 et le
18 dans l'est dans les collèges nous
avons travaillé pour cela sur le régime
de responsabilité des maires le premier
ministre a répondu il ya actuellement un
régime de responsabilité qui fait qu'il
n'ya pas de risque particulier pour les
mères dans cette période actuelle c'est
un long débat et il aura lieu dans cette
chambre ainsi que à la chambre et autres
je crois puisqu'il ya plusieurs
questions
et puis s'agissant de votre troisième
question c'est à dire la question la
question de l'année 2020 2021 c'est une
question extrêmement important parce
qu'en effet l'année 2020 2021 ne sera
pas comme les autres d'une part soit le
virus ne sera plus là on peut l'espérer
et dans ce cas il faudra tenir compte
des retards qui ont eu lieu pour les
élèves soit il sera encore là est ce que
nous sommes en train de faire en mai
juin nous sera évidemment très utile
pour avoir une vision mixte hybride et
je crois a réussi de la scolarité des
enfants
merci monsieur le ministre nous
poursuivons maintenant notre séance avec
des questions pourtant sur des thèmes
économiques et sociaux
la parole est à monsieur jean-luc la
glaise merci monsieur le président ma
question s'adresse au ministre
l'économie et des finances le transport
aérien mondial les compagnies aériennes
les aéroports les industriels maître
d'oeuvre et la sous traitance sont
touchés de plein fouet par la crise du
kobe 19 95% des avions dans le monde
sont cloués au sol en région occitanie
particulièrement dans mon département en
garonne airbus est le plus gros
employeur de cette filière industrielle
de pointe qui subit aujourd'hui un coup
de frein brutal au tour de toulouse ce
sont cinquante à cent mille emplois qui
pourraient être détruits d'ici quelques
mois vous l'aurez compris si cette
filière plonge
nous allons au devant de conséquences
économiques et sociales dramatiques
vous avez annoncé des mesures sans
précédent pour sauver air france klm par
le biais de 7 milliards d'euros de prêts
garantis par l'état et c'est tant mieux
il faut aussi sauver la filière
aéronautique des grands groupes
jusqu'aux pm une filière qui est la
seule filière industrielle en france a
contribué positivement pour plus de 30
millions d'euros à notre balance
commerciale
nous devons donc transformer cette crise
une occasion unique d'aller plus vite et
plus fort avait de grands programmes
comme au temps du lancement de l'a320
il faut aller plus vite et plus fort
vers une décarbonisation de l'aérien il
faut aller plus vite et plus fort vers
une transformation numérique de guccione
est de l'outil industriel ait encore une
fois depuis les grands groupes jusqu'aux
pays aux pme il faut aller plus vite et
plus fort en lançant un nouveau fonds
d'investissement dédié de type héros
fang pour irriguer toute la filière
dans ce contexte de crise inédit face au
soutien massif des états unis et de la
chine à leur propre constructeur quels
moyens comptez-vous employés pour sauver
toute notre filière aéronautique et pour
préserver le savoir-faire de nos pme de
nos étés y des appétits chinois et à
toulouse c'est ce que c'est les appétits
chinois
merci chers collègues la porte aval
allemagne espagne et une ag secrétaire
d'état auprès du ministre de l'économie
et des finances
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés monsieur le député
la glaise vous avez raison
l'aéronautique c'est une filière de
premier ordre en france nous sommes le
seul pays avec les états unis
encore aujourd'hui être capable de
construire de a à z
un avion est d'avoir tous les corps de
métiers et toutes les compétences
présentes sur notre territoire et vous
avez également raison de noter que dans
la situation actuelle où l'aviation
commerciale est particulièrement touchée
et où les programmes d'investissements
sont par conséquent ce quasiment à zéro
il y a un impact majeur pour notre
filière aéronautique alors comment
avons-nous agit depuis quelques semaines
d'abord nous avons été immédiatement en
contact de cette filière que ce soit le
ministère des transports le ministère
des armées au ministère de l'économie
pour les accompagner dans trois
directions
la première la mise en place des mesures
d'urgence parce qu'elle était nécessaire
le chômage partiel est venu
particulièrement à propos pour sauver
des compétences rares puisqu'il faut dix
ans pour former certaines compétences
dans l'aéronautique
la deuxième chose c'est effectivement
d'accompagner la reprise du travail dans
des conditions sanitaires irréprochable
et ça nous a pris beaucoup de temps de
discussion avec les organisations
syndicales et avec les entreprises
justement pour trouver c'est juste
équilibre pour reprendre le travail et
répondre à la demande mondiale puisqu'on
continue de produire dans les autres
productions
la troisième chose c'est de préparer la
suite bruno le maire l'a dit hier il
souhaite un plan de relance pour la
filière aéronautique il souhaite un plan
de soutien
et ce plan de soutien doit être à la
mesure des enjeux auxquels nous faisons
face
il est trop tôt pour en dessiner
parfaitement les concours tournez ce qui
est sûr c'est qu'il nous avons trois
objectifs le premier vous l'avez dit
c'est d'assurer la compétitivité de
cette filière en investissant dans
l'industrie du futur le deuxième c'est
la transition écologique
nous sommes les meilleurs dans ce
domaine là continuons à creuser cet
avantage concurrentiel
enfin le troisième c'est effectivement
d'accompagner peut-être certaines
reconversion nous y travaillons avec la
filière nous réunirons demain le comité
stratégique de filière je vous remercie
la parole est à mme lauriane rossi merci
merci monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le ministre de
l'économie et j'y associe les député des
hauts-de-seine de mon groupe
cette crise sanitaire nous le savons est
un choc terrible pour les entrepreneurs
les indépendants et les salariés de
notre pays
à vos côtés monsieur le ministre nous
mettons tout en oeuvre pour les aider et
les accompagner c'est ainsi que le 23
avril dernier nous avons adopté ce
deuxième collectif budgétaire qui a
permis d'améliorer encore le plan d'
aide économique d'urgence
un soutien qui a encore été renforcé
hier par le gouvernement en décidant
d'annuler les charges des charges
sociales des petites entreprises de
moins de dix salariés qui ont dû fermé
sur décision administrative durant le
confinement je veux saluer ses efforts
budgétaires exceptionnelles au service
de nos emplois pour autant certains
entrepreneurs commerçants artisans -
interpellé comme beaucoup ici sur ces
bancs car leur situation n'entre pas
toujours dans les critères de ces aides
c'est le cas des entreprises
individuelles donc 100 salariés qui ne
sont pas éligibles à la subvention de
base et à l'aide complémentaire
par ailleurs le fonds de solidarité
exige d'avoir réalisé au cours du
dernier exercice un bénéfice de 60 mille
euros maximum incluant les rémunérations
du dirigeant un seuil qui exclut encore
un nombre important d'entrepreneurs de
notre pays
enfin certaines petites entreprises
commerces restaurants qui n'étaient pas
en difficulté jusqu'au confinement
pourrait bien le devenir en raisons des
refus de prêts parfois opposées par
certaines banques qui vont jusqu'à leur
conseiller la liquidation parfois sans
motifs parfois au motif que ce sont des
tpe ou pme trop jeunes ou trop à risque
inversement le prêt garanti par l'état a
été élargie aux entreprises dites en
difficulté c'est à dire celle qui était
en procédure de redressement ou de
liquidation après le 31 décembre 2019
qu'en est il des pme qui était en
procédure collective avant cette date et
qui en sont sortis depuis
plus largement pouvez-vous nous
renseigner le seul ministre sur
l'évolution des dispositifs d aide aux
petites et moyennes entreprises qui font
la vitalité de notre pays et le
dynamisme de nos territoires
je vous remercie
merci chers collègues la parole est à
madame agnès pannier rina g secrétaire
d'état auprès du ministre de l'économie
et des finances merci monsieur le
président mesdames et messieurs les
députés madame la députée rossi vous dit
avec beaucoup de justesse à quel point
ces petites entreprises sont nécessaires
à notre pays
non seulement leur vie économique mais
également à ce lien social qui est
précieuse sur l'ensemble des territoires
et je veux redire ici à quel point le
ministère de l'économie bruno le maire
et moi même sommes à engager aux côtés
de ces entreprises et nous avons sans
cesse améliorer les dispositifs
économiques en écoutant d'ailleurs les
recommandations de la représentation
nationale sur certains éléments de
dispositif qui devait être élargi
c'est en ce sens par exemple
effectivement nous avons élargi le prêt
garanti par l'état aux entreprises en
difficulté qui sont rentrés en
difficulté après le 1er janvier 2020 et
que pour répondre à votre question
toutes les entreprises qui ont mis en
place un plan de continuation et donc
qu'ils sont sortis de leurs difficultés
peuvent se prévaloir auprès de leur
banque de cette situation et demander un
prêt garanti par l'état je veux
également dire que nous avons complété
notre dispositif grâce aux votes du bfr
r2 que vous avez porté avec nous
notamment avec 500 millions d'euros
d'avancés remboursables destinée plus
particulièrement aux pme et également
avec le travail d'élargissement du fonds
de solidarité qui permet désormais
d'activer le deuxième volet de ce fonds
pour les entreprises qui n'ont pas de
salarié c'était une question qui avait
été beaucoup discuté nous avons su
entendre vos recommandations sur ce
sujet enfin dernier point comme vous le
savez notre plan va s'élargir pour les
entreprises qui ne pourront pas
reprendre le travail au mois de mai je
pense aux hôtels aux restaurants des
hôtels pardon sont pas mourir mais au
restaurant et un certain nombre
d'activités touristiques pour ces
entreprises en particulier le plan est
prolongée il est même renforcée puisque
l'ensemble des aides vont pour les
entreprises jusqu'à 20 salariés et 2
millions d'euros de chiffre d'affaires
merci madame la ministre la parole de
monsieur pierre vatin
merci monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le ministre de
l'économie et des finances madame la
ministre en l'occurrence vous nous avez
annoncé depuis deux mois que le
gouvernement ne laisserait pas
d'entreprise sur le bord du chemin dans
la traversée de la crise ducobu 19 que
nous connaissons or pour les
indépendants commerçants et artisans qui
travaillent seuls
la situation devient critique
heureusement à la demande des
républicains à notre demande donc vous
venez hier d'accepter de supprimer la
condition d' employer un salarié pour
pouvoir bénéficier du fonds de
solidarité et je m'en réjouis avec mes
collègues malheureusement l'annoncent
politique veut que vous faites va créer
beaucoup de déception chez des petits
commerçants et artisans que vous
prétendez aider en effet vous
conditionnez restrictivement cette aide
au fonds de solidarité au fait de ne pas
avoir obtenu deux prêts garantis par
l'état
pourtant les deux dispositifs ne sont
pas comparables et ne doivent pas être
exclusifs l'un de l'autre
cette exclusion ne manquera pas d'en
défavorisés de nombreux alors que la
grande majorité de ces chefs
d'entreprise n'a aucune visibilité sur
la reprise de son activité
se pose aussi le problème des loyers des
entreprises très peu de propriétaires
privés peuvent s'en faire grâce à
l'entreprise locataire ses propriétaires
sont souvent de modestes retraités dont
le loyer constituent une part
substantielle de la retraite mensuelle
quelles réponses proposez-vous pour
éviter de que la dette supplémentaire à
ces petites entreprises et des
difficultés financières aux modestes
retraités propriétaires de plus avec la
proche du déconfinement ces
entrepreneurs vont devoir s'acquitter
aussi sans savoir comment faire de la
dette créée par le report de charges
fiscales et d'emprunts au delà des
charges sociales je vous demande de nous
dire si vous êtes prêt à annuler les
charges fiscales de l'ensemble des
hôtels cafés restaurants et commerces
je vous demande si l'état prendra en
charge les intérêts inconnue à ce jour
qui nous manqueront pas d'être générés
par les p geo non remboursé dans les
délais contractuels
enfin qu'en est il de notre demande
d'extension du pge dans le temps qu'en
est il de notre demande d'extension du
fonds de solidarité 7 milliards d'euros
actuellement bien modeste au regard des
difficultés de notre petite entreprise
dans le nécessaire accompagnement dont
elles auront besoin dans la sortie du
confinement pour favoriser la reprise
économique
je vous remercie chocolat panier
secrétaire d'état auprès du ministre de
l'économie et des finances merci
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés monsieur le député
vin vous l'avez dit nous avons amélioré
ce dispositif gelé - même affirmé grâce
à un certain nombre de des changes que
nous avons eues avec les élus nationaux
mais également les élus de terrain je
veux rappeler d'ailleurs que les régions
sur ce sujet avait d'abord une position
qui était plutôt de considérer que le
deuxième volet du fonds ne devait
bénéficier que aux entreprises qui
avaient un salarié et plus
et cette discussion a été fructueuse
puisque nous avons collectivement
finalement décidé d'élargir le font donc
vous voyez cette prise en compte du
terrain de la parole elle peut être à
géométrie variable selon les fonctions
mais à tout le moins on peut nous
l'accorder pour aller plus loin je veux
rappeler qu'effectivement dans le
dispositif aujourd'hui existants le
deuxième volet du fonds les 5000 euros
additionnel auxquels peuvent prétendre
les petits commerçants et les petits
artisans
il vise précisément à couvrir ses
charges
lot 4 et locatif auxquels font face à un
certain nombre d'artisans et de
commerçants
c'est à ça que ça sert et ça permet
également justement au petit retraité
qui ne vit que de ses loyers de pouvoir
conserver ses loyers donc voilà une
réponse précise et concrète à votre
question
et puis rappelons que depuis déjà deux
mois à la demande des commerçants et des
artisans il est possible d'obtenir un
dégrèvement fiscal de ses impôts directs
cela est mise en place depuis mi mars
maintenant donc je veux leur rappeler ce
n'est certes pas automatique mais
lorsque vous fait valoir des difficultés
particulières de trésorerie vous le
retrouverez sur le site du ministère de
l'économie très complet pour accompagner
les entreprises
il est tout à fait possible d'activer ce
dispositif
au global je me félicite de voir un
fonds de solidarité de 7 milliards 2,7
milliards d'euros avec la participation
des régions 500 millions d'euros 400
millions d'euros des assurances et
d'avoir un dispositif complémentaire
pour les restaurants et activités
touristiques aujourd'hui fermée qui va
encore plus loin et sur lequel nous
continuons à travailler
merci madame la ministre la palette à
monsieur sébastien jumel la parole c'est
le président ce premier ministre la
force du groupe communiste sa richesse
c'est notamment sa composante
ultramarines et nos collègues
ultramarins depuis trois semaines vous
alerte sur la situation très
préoccupante du fret aérien à
destination des territoires d'outre-mer
en effet alors que le nombre de
rotations a été divisé jusqu'à 17 fois
aux antilles et que la compagnie air
france se trouve en situation de
monopole de quasi monopole sur les
desserts d'outre-mer le coût du fret est
multiplié par 3 voire par quatre le
surcoût est telle que la grande
distribution ne recourent plus au fret
aérien avec les producteurs locaux ne
peuvent plus suivre pour leur
approvisionnement
la filière avicole et pour par exemple
en très grande difficulté pire des
entreprises ont toutes les peines du
monde à faire venir le matériel de
protection sanitaire nécessaire à la
sécurité de leur personnel en prévision
du déconfinement nos inquiétudes sont
d'autant plus grandes que la fermeture
prolongée de la plateforme d'orly d'une
part et la mise en garde par le
président de l'ihh atea de
l'augmentation de 50% des prix du billet
en cas d'application des mesures de
distanciation envol d'autre part font
peser de lourdes inquiétudes quant à la
desserte de nos territoires d'outre-mer
madame la ministre la continuité
territoriale la continuité économique
exige des mesures fortes notamment en
titre des obligations de service public
ainsi ma question est simple comptez
vous assurer rapidement un service de
fret à prix régulés a pris conventionnés
et par ailleurs comptez vous garantir la
sécurité sanitaire
sans explosion tarifaire merci monsieur
le député l'apport alto madame annick
girardin ministre d outre mer monsieur
le président mesdames et messieurs les
députés monsieur le député jumelles
cette crise a en effet une influence une
conséquence sur les coûts du fret aérien
national et international vous avez
raison c'est deux fois trois fois le
prix pourquoi tout simplement parce que
vous le savez en temps normal 60 % du
fret aérien est financé par le prix des
billets de passagers c'est comme ça
qu'on finance des projets aujourd'hui
les compagnies aériennes ont perdu 90%
de leurs passagers sur la totalité de
notre planète
alors oui les territoires d'outre-mer
qui sont aussi malheureusement touchées
par cette pandémie et surtout depuis le
23 mars nous avons décidé de limiter les
vols dans les territoires d'outre-mer
voire même de les supprimer dans
certains cas notamment pour mayotte où
nous passons avec un pont aérien à
partir de la réunion
et bien il y a eu des incidences sur les
prix on passe de 4 à 5 euros le kilo à
10 à 12 euros aujourd'hui le kilo c'est
grosso modo ce qui est pratiqué sur
l'ensemble de la planète mais ce n'est
pas effectivement une explication
suffisante
on savait qu'il y aurait un impact quand
on a décidé de limiter les vols à deux à
trois par semaine on le savait mais la
priorité était la santé et nous
maintenant aujourd'hui que la priorité
la santé
toutefois on a fait un certain nombre
d'actions d'abord on a souhaité
effectivement que cette capacité de fret
elle puisse continuer ça s'appelle la
continuité territoriale minimale et nous
l'avons fait avec deux trois liaisons
par semaine et ses liaisons la air
france air austral c'est au coude avant
il n'y a pas d'augmentation sur ses
tarifs
il n'y a pas d'augmentation non plus sur
tous les produits où tous les moyens
matériels luttant contre ce virus que
nous envoyons dans les territoires
ultramarins
après il ya des vols spécifique fret qui
ont été mis en place
hélas oui il ya un coût supplémentaire
il n'y a pas de passage et ça répond à
votre même question et puis nous avons
regardé aussi sur les consommateurs
en travaillant avec la grande
distribution sur des chartes de
modération des prix et puis bien sûr il
ya le maintenant qu'est-ce qu'on fait
bien on fait plusieurs choses d'abord
nous avons le souhait de ramener les
étudiants chez eux ça fait dix mille
jeunes doivent rentrer dans les
territoires ultramarins y aura plus de
vols dans plus de fred donc moins cher
et puis nous travaillons aussi à une
aide
et puis on travaille surtout au delà du
mois de juin à une réouverture des
territoires d'outre-mer ce que ça se
prépare
merci madame la ministre nous terminons
notre séance avec des questions portant
à monsieur jumelles pardon je vous
laisse compléter
pardonnez moi
il me restait 24 secondes qui me
permettent d'attirer l'attention de
madame laminé sur les étudiants
d'outre-mer qui sont à diact accueilli
depuis 1964 à l'efficace 200 jeunes
ultramarins qui sont repartis chez eux
pour être protégé mais dont on espère
bien qu'il retrouve le chemin de livres
casse à la rentrée prochaine donc je
voulais attirer votre attention sur
l'importance que nous attachons à ce
titre bisman de formation de qualité sur
le territoire si le mans et monsieur
jumelles la parole à monsieur alexis
corbière
merci président mes chers collègues ma
question s'adresse au ministre de la
culture sur le ministre depuis le 15
mars le monde des arts et du spectacle
est à l'arrêt les salles de spectacles
sont fermés les tournages sont
interrompus les festivals sont annulés
etc
en conséquence en raison notamment de la
manière parfois complaisent la fonction
de cette profession ce sont près de 1.5
millions de nos concitoyens
indispensable à notre vie démocratique
mais aussi essentielle à notre vie
économique car je rappelle que la
culture représente une part de notre pib
cette fois de plus importante que
l'industrie automobile ce secteur est en
danger certes le 18 mars le ministre
vous avez débloqué 22 millions d'euros
pour ce secteur mais je dois le dire
c'est peu de chose à titre d'exemple
l'allemagne à d'ores et déjà débloqué 50
milliards d'euros
et rien que le secteur de la librairie
auquel nous tenons tous sans doute
mériterait au moins 26 millions d'euros
pour ne pas voir ses portes fermées deux
pétitions actuellement circulent
l'une nommé année noire vous les
connaissez l'autre culture en danger
elles ont récolté au moins 250 mille
signatures et elle réclame tout un plan
d'urgence une coordination des
intermittents animée notamment par
samuel churin vous demande une année
blanche c'est-à-dire pour être précis la
prolongation des droits de tous les
artistes et techniciens intermittents
d'une année de leur indemnisation par
l'unedic
sur la base de l'année 2019 êtes vous
d'accord avec cette revendication que
nous soutenons et qui nous semble
essentiel
toutes ces pétitions et appels sont
accompagnés notamment depuis ce matin
deux grands devoirs je pense à celles
d'isabelle adjani d'arrière
askari de marina foïs et combien de
grands artistes qui sont toutes
solidaires de ces métiers indispensables
à la culture technicien costumier
éclairagiste maquillage etc
n'oublions pas aussi les artistes
auteurs dont le statut est des plus
précaires
à quand une adaptation du fonds de
solidarité pour ce secteur
bref quelle est votre opinion monsieur
le ministre ne pouvait pas attendre la
parole du président de la république
votre gouvernement qui a si souvent
valoriser la culture de l'argent
mettra-t-il de l'argent dans la culture
décret trèbes où un état d'urgence
culturel la parole est à monsieur franck
l'espère ministre de la culture
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés monsieur le député
corbières tout à l'heure je vais avoir
l'occasion je crois savoir à de répondre
à une question sur les fausses
informations vous en avez relier une
très grosse tout à l'heure concernant le
plan de 50 milliards d'euros de
l'allemagne pour la culture c'est
évidemment une un fox puisque ce plan de
50 milliards visait la totalité
l'économie allemande est pas simplement
la culture pour autant vous avez raison
le secteur de la culture est
parfaitement et terriblement touchés par
ces crises et nous devons être à la
hauteur de ce qu'apportent les acteurs
de la culture à notre pays à nos
compatriotes on voit pendant le
confinement et on nous le verrons bien
évidemment en sortie de crise en ce qui
concerne spécifiquement les
intermittents le gouvernement dès le
début de la crise a comme vous l'avez
rappelé pris des mesures très fortes
l'accès au chômage partiel pour les
entreprises qui emploient des
intermittents le fait de prolonger la
période de calcul des heures qui permet
de bénéficier du régime de
l'intermittence pour sanctuariser cette
période et pour que personne qui aurait
pu acquérir des droits pendant la
période puisse être pénalisé et pour ce
malgré tout qu'ils sortent sortirait du
dispositif d'intermittence un fonds
spécial de professionnalisation de
solidarités gérés avec audience en
collaboration avec audience va permettre
de faire en sorte que personne ne soit
laissé sur le bord du chemin
quant à l'avenir nous savons tous que le
spectacle vivant va me prendre du temps
à retrouver le chemin des théâtres des
salles de concerts et des festivals et
nous avons donc là
nécessité d'accompagner cet écosystème
si important et nous travaillons avec
muriel pénicaud avec les collègues du
ministère de l'économie des finances
sous l'autorité du premier ministre pour
faire en sorte que nous puissions avoir
un dispositif d'accompagnement le plus
efficace pour cible pour permettre de
faire en sorte d'accompagner les
artistes et les techniciens qui
bénéficient de ce régime de
l'intermittence
ils sont l'âme de notre culture est si
essentiel à toute les spectacles vivants
l'audiovisuel et le cinéma vous pouvez
compter sur nous pour trouver les
réponses à leurs problèmes
merci monsieur le ministre la parole que
monsieur olivier faure merci monsieur le
président monsieur le premier ministre
je devrais revenir sous état d'urgence
sociale je les ai entendus dans toutes
les bouches
cette crise est un révélateur des
inégalités très bien et alors on pose
salars et puis on attend que ça se passe
on considère que l'on rende rsa un monde
meilleur qui comme l'horizon recule
toujours où est-ce qu'on se retrousse
les manches tout de suite pour que la
justice progresse je vais donc sur la
table
cinq propositions première proposition
celle de l'abrogation de la réforme de
l'assurance chômage
les nouvelles règles que vous avez posé
vont avoir des effets dévastateurs
comment ceux qui n'ont pas pu travailler
du fait des crises sanitaires seraient
demain se verraient imposer une double
peine allez vous oui ou non
renoncer définitivement à cette réforme
de l'assurance chômage
deuxième point la prolongation du
chômage partiel
l'éducation se suivent sans se
ressembler allez vous maintenir le
chômage partiel dans sa forme actuelle
sans dégressivité au delà du 1er juin
y compris pour les parents qui ne
souhaitent pas le retour de leur enfant
à l'école
troisième point le matindz d'urgence
pour les personnes précaires
la pauvreté ne se déconfit n'aura pas à
la semaine prochaine vous avez accepté
d'instaurer une aide minimale d'un mois
que ferez vous au mois de mai
acceptez-vous un moratoire sur les
expulsions locatives dans le parc social
quatrième point
un droit aux vacances et à
l'accompagnement scolaire pour les
enfants qui en ont besoin
pourquoi ne pas financer pendant les
grandes vacances des emplois jeunes pour
les accompagner y compris sur le plan
scolaire pour aborder la rentrée dans de
meilleures conditions
cinquième point et j'en finis par là le
seul premier ministre manière
proposition tient en un seul mot justice
les plus riches doivent aussi être ceux
qui contribuent le plus dans le cadre
d'une régie qualité réforme et acceptez
vous de vous acceptez vous de répartir
les efforts afin de ne pas creuser
davantage les inégalités l'asie merci
monsieur faure la parole était un
monsieur le premier ministre
[Musique]
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés
monsieur le député olivier faure vous
avez raison le confinement
l'interruption quasi complète pas
complète quasi complète de l'activité
économique conduit directement à une
crise sociale qui ne sera pas moins
préoccupante que la crise économique ou
que la crise pédagogique le cas échéant
que nous allons devoir affronter
lorsque nous seront sortis ou lorsque
nous sortirons progressivement de la
crise sanitaire
avant d'essayer de répondre à quelques
unes des questions que vous avez posé je
me permets de vous faire observer que
même si je n'attends pas du tout de
votre part de satisfecit sur les mesures
qui ont été mises en oeuvre
nous aurions pu collectivement remarqué
parce que c'est très spécifique à la
france
infiniment plus efficace et plus
généreux que ce qui a été mis en place
au royaume uni ou en espagne ou en
italie ou en allemagne
ou bien sûr aux états unis ou en vérité
partout ailleurs
nous avons mis en place un cadre social
assez unique est assez exceptionnel avec
des mesures très différentes qui visait
à traiter les spécificités d'un certain
nombre de publics les plus fragiles
qu'ils soient salariés confrontés à la
rupture d'activité qu'il soit non
salariés avec des mécanismes qui ont
permis la préservation des droits qu'ils
soient allocataires de minima sociaux ou
de prestations sociales
tout à l'heure je répondais je crois au
président et aux députés non pardon au
président jacob sur les comparaisons
vous avez peut-être observé qu'en france
en dépit de difficultés considérables
et même si des critiques ont été
formulées à la poche les versements des
allocations sociales
en début de mois ont été réalisées en
italie le gouvernement a été confronté à
une situation terrible à des critiques
féroces parce que il n'avait pas été en
mesure c'est pas moi qui vais lui jeter
la première pierre
justement d'assurer le versement dans
les temps de ces allocations
autrement dit reconnaissons d'abord que
notre pays
certains diront à cause de décisions du
gouvernement je ne m'attends pas autant
mais néanmoins notre pays a su répondre
à l'urgence sociale
je ne dis pas que c'est parfait le dit
que probablement aucun pays n'en a fait
autant et que nous devrions en être fier
et que nous devrions le défendre que
nous devrions l'expliquer plutôt que de
pointer et vous êtes parfaitement dans
votre rôle en disant ça et là il y a des
choses qui peuvent être améliorées
plutôt que de pointer seulement les
banques je le dis et encore une fois je
je je ne je ne cherche pas de polémique
vous non plus je le répète puisque je
pense que c'est essentiel vous avez
ensuite posé plusieurs questions sur le
chômage partiel
nous avons indiqué la nécessité de
poursuivre le régime actuel le plus
généreux d'europe jusqu'à la fin du mois
de mai c'est décidé nous n'y revenons
pas et j'ai indiqué à cette tribune la
semaine dernière qu' il faudrait faire
évoluer ce dispositif
après le 1er juin en fonction d'ailleurs
d évolution de l'épidémie
nous n'allons pas pouvoir vous le savez
parfaitement en tout cas je pense que
chacun a bien conscience nous n'allons
pas pouvoir dans la durée maintenir un
système aussi généreux que celui qui est
mis en place pour les entreprises pour
les salariés et notre objectif c'est
donc au fur et à mesure de la reprise de
l'activité qui va arriver
adapter progressivement progressivement
mais adapter ce régime de l'activité
partielle pour faire en sorte qu'ils
puissent en s'adaptant accompagner la
reprise de l'activité
nous verrons les conditions dans
lesquelles nous l'adaptons il y aura des
discussions avec les organisations
syndicales et avec les organisations
représentatives du personnel il y aura
évidemment des dispositions qui sont
présentés dans cette assemblée et au
sénat mais je crois utile de dire que
oui en effet passé le plus dur de la
crise sanitaire car nous espérons tous
cas la fin du mois de mai nous avons
passé le plus dur de la crise sanitaire
même si je reste prudent nous pourrons
adapter progressivement ce dispositif
sur l'assurance chômage nous avons déjà
indiqué que nous reportions un certain
nombre de mesures qui devait entrer en
vigueur
alors que la crise sanitaire avait
commencé que nous n'entendions pas
revenir sur des choses qui avait été
décidé et mis en oeuvre
auparavant là encore les partenaires
sociaux confrontait je pense aux
difficultés de financement de tous les
dispositifs sociaux notamment du
dispositif de l'assurance chômage
discuterons ensemble et avec nous des
adaptations qu'il convient de faire
mais gardons tous à l'esprit que la
reprise de l'activité doit s'accompagner
de dispositifs qui vont permettre au
maximum d'entre nous de repartir avec le
filet de solidarité qui est absolument
essentiel dans notre pays et que
d'ailleurs personne ne songe à remettre
en cause mais en favorisant dans toute
la mesure du possible la reprise de
l'activité
je vous ai indiqué les principes que
nous avions fixés vous vous proposez
monsieur le député c'est une proposition
qu'il faut entendre qu'il faut traiter
le retour le développement des emplois
jeunes c'est une idée qui n'est pas
nouvelle
la coupe et l'à beaucoup été utilisé
dans le passé d'ailleurs assez
différemment en fonction des majorités
parfois avec plus de vigueur que
d'autres enfin néanmoins on connaît on
connaît les emplois jeunes je ne suis
pas certain pour ma part que ces emplois
est démontré dans la durée une
efficacité manifeste s'agissant de
l'amélioration du modèle social de notre
pays je n'en suis pas sûr je pense que
non mais on en parlera sans doute je
pense que ils ont parfois un intérêt est
souvent des inconvénients majeurs
c'est ce que j'observe au niveau
national c'est parfois même ce que j'ai
observé dans mon expérience locale où
j'ai vu des systèmes pérenniser beaucoup
plus que des mécanismes qui permettait à
des jeunes gens de saint céré et d'aller
directement vers l'activité bon mais
nous aurons l'occasion d'en parler c'est
un débat ancien est intéressant je ne
suis pas sûr que ce soit l'instrument
idéal pour aller vers la révolution
sociale ou plus exactement vers le
progrès social que vous évoquez en tout
état de cause évidemment en sortie de
crise sanitaire
nous devrons adapter nos mécanismes et
nos instruments d'accompagnement des
plus fragiles chacun le sait la question
ce sera dans quelle optique avec quelle
idée de l'insertion avec quelle idée du
rebond économique
avec quel projet pour l'ensemble des
personnes les plus fragiles les
accompagner oui leur permettent de
retourner vers l'activité oui faire en
sorte qu'ils puissent dans toute la
mesure s'épanouir et aller de l'avant
oui bien sûr ce sera un débat politique
je ne crois pas que le temps soit venu
de trancher mais il aura lieu et je m'en
félicite
merci monsieur le premier ministre la
parole à monsieur jean pierre cubertafon
le président
monsieur le premier ministre mes chers
collègues je tiens à associer mes
collègues de dordogne cette question le
plan national de déconfinement prévoient
notamment la réouverture progressive des
écoles élémentaire et maternelle à
partir du 11 mai sous la responsabilité
des maires nous sommes à leurs côtés
dans ce moment important pour nos
communes et pour chaque famille que je
tiens à saluer sur sur le terrain nombre
d'entre eux mettent tout en oeuvre pour
accueillir les enfants dès la semaine
prochaine tout en s'interrogeant face à
cette situation inédite
d'autres fort heureusement peu nombreux
après avoir légitimement réclamer que la
gestion de la crise soient confiées au
plus près du terrain
s'inquiète du poids de cette
responsabilité il nous faut rassurer les
uns et les autres nous devons appeler
rappeler la protection qu'apporte la loi
dite fauchon de notre ancien collègue
centriste votée en 2000 et qui protège
les élus comme tout citoyenne de
condamnations en cas de faute non
intentionnelle dans les circonstances
présentes complexe à l'extrême il ne
s'agit d'aller ni en deçà ni au delà de
cette responsabilité ni en deçà nous
devons préciser pour tous les maires les
questions qui restent incertaines enfin
de les sécuriser juridiquement
ainsi monsieur le premier ministre vous
nous confirmer que le pouvoir
d'ouverture des écoles revient à l'état
le rôle du maire étant de vérifier que
les conditions fixées par le protocole
sanitaire sont remplies et d'assurer la
bonne gestion de leurs personnels
municipaux ni au delà si un maire
s'éloigner de manière intentionnelle des
objectifs d'intérêt général
sa responsabilité individuelle doit
demeurer engagée
monsieur le premier ministre les maires
comme chef d'entreprise ne réclame pas
de bénéfice d'une immunité contraire à
leur vocation
mais devant l'ampleur des menaces
l'incertitude des solutions
l'accroissement de la complexité des
normes et la judiciarisation croissante
de la société
nous attendons que le gouvernement
réaffirme droit en ce qui nous protège
tous et en ce qu'il engage chacun je
vous remercie
merci chers collègues la parole est à
madame nicole belloubet garde des sceaux
ministre de la justice monsieur pardon
monsieur le président mesdames les
députés messieurs les députés michel
député cubertafon hier devant le sénat
monsieur le premier ministre et moi-même
ensuite à l'occasion de l'examen du
projet de loi sur l'état d'urgence
sanitaire avons dit à quel point le
gouvernement était sensible aux
inquiétudes qui pouvait peser sur les
élus en matière de risque pénal qui pèse
sur les mères et au delà d'ailleurs sur
l'ensemble des décideurs notamment en
cette période de reprise d'activité
nous avons également rappeler que l'été
l'état du droit et cet état du droit en
matière de déclenchement de la
responsabilité pénale j'ai eu l'occasion
de le dire est assez restrictif en cas
de faute involontaire bien entendu
puisque d'une part il exige que l'on
recherche un comportement qui soit un
comportement sciemment dangereux ne
prenons pas soin d'autrui et que d'autre
part la chambre criminelle de la cour de
cassation va de manière systématique
pour voir s'il ya une faute éventuelle
affaire une après une appréciation in
concreto c'est à dire au cas par cas
dans un objectif de réassurance vous
avez utilisé ce verbe le verbe près
assurée dans un objectif de réassurance
des élus il me paraît cependant
souhaitable de clarifier les textes
existants dans la loi il me semble en
effet important de prendre en compte et
les compétences propres de chacun des
décideurs et les connaissances
personnelles dont il dispose au moment
où se passent les événements c'est un
préalable qui s'imposent dont la
recherche d'une éventuelle
responsabilité pénale dans le cadre de
la crise sanitaire comme vous le dites
il est important en effet de lever toute
incertitude pour l'ensemble des
décideurs les élus mais pour l'ensemble
des décideurs face aux responsabilités
face aux décisions qu'ils doivent
prendre pendant cette période de crise
du colis de 19 mais il est également
essentiel et vous l'avez également très
bien rappelé que cette évolution
législative s'inscrivent tout d'abord
dans le respect du principe
constitutionnel d'égalité
il est aussi tout à fait essentiel
en évitant un risque pénal excessif que
ces dispositions traduisent l'equilibre
qui doit nécessairement exister entre la
responsabilité et la prise de décision
c'est en ce sens que je suis prête à
travailler avec le parlement
merci madame lagarde des jo la parole
est à madame george pau langevin
merci monsieur le président mes chers
collègues
monsieur des ministres de l'intérieur la
crise du coronavirus et le confinement
nous font tous vivre dans un climat
d'angoissé et de nervosité policiers
comme citoyen et mon groupe c'est bien
que nos forces de sécurité sont soumises
à rude épreuve depuis quelques années
entre la lutte contre le terrorisme
intégriste
les manifestations violentes les
agressions dont ils sont la cible est
maintenant leur participation à la lutte
contre ce virus inconnu
pour autant il nous semble que les
forces de l'ordre
aujourd'hui on recourt fréquemment à des
méthodes très critiquables et des
incidents préoccupant nous sont
régulièrement rapportés
vous avez réagi rapidement ainsi que
votre secrétaire d'état pour suspendre
les fonctionnaires fautifs à l'île saint
denis et réaffirmé que le racisme n'a
pas sa place dans la police républicaine
il conviendra de tenir informée la
représentation nationale sur les suites
disciplinaires apporter à cette affaire
mais la multiplication de ce type de
dérapage telle qu'elle sera là tu es
démontre la nécessité d'un véritable
plan de lutte contre les agissements et
les propos racistes au sein de nos
forces sécurité par exemple en
renforçant la formation sur les droits
de la personne et en impliquant mieux la
hiérarchie il est question de renforcer
les enquêtes ce n'est as sur les agents
à recruter ou en fonction ne serait-il
pas utile de poser des questions dans
ses enquêtes sur les positions de
l'agent concernant les questions de
racisme de discrimination de manière à
mener mieux une politique préventive
cette question apparaît d'autant plus
importante aujourd'hui que le
confinement se prolonge en nombre
d'activités
habituellement composé aux jeunes dans
les quartiers risque de ne pouvoir être
mises en oeuvre
avec l'accroissement et vit dans des
tentes y sont que
va entraîner monsieur le ministre quel
politique de fond allez vous mener pour
que l'image d'une police gardienne du
pacte républicain soit préservée dans
nos quartiers merci chers collègues la
parole là monsieur christophe castaner
ministre de l'intérieur monsieur le
président mesdames messieurs député
madame la députée george pau langevin
vous avez raison vous l'avez rappelé le
racisme n'a pas sa place dans la police
républicaine et jamais ni la police ni
la gendarmerie ne doit accepter des mots
comme ce que l'on a entendu il y a dix
joueurs que j'ai et vous l'avez rappelé
immédiatement condamné et une enquête
est ouverte qu'au moment où je vous
parle et devra faire toute la vérité et
je voudrais souligner le paradoxe de
cette séquence là quelques minutes avant
l'un des deux auteurs et les deux
auteurs se sont auto dénoncer parce
qu'ils ont compris la gravité de leurs
propos mais quelques minutes avant l'un
des deux auteurs n'a pas hésité à sauter
dans la seine pour sauver celui qui
fuyait les forces de police après un
cambriolage à ce moment là je suis sûr
qu'il ne s'est pas posé la question de
savoir si c'était un étranger si c'était
un musulman si c'était un chrétien
quelles étaient ses opinions politiques
il a sauté dans la seine pour lui porter
secours et quelques minutes après il a
ses mots totalement insupportable
totalement condamnable cela à travers
cette histoire d'hommes de femmes montre
aussi la fragilité la fragilité que l'on
peut tout savoir mais une fragilité
insupportable quand on sert la police
républicaine et vos mots comme les miens
sont les mots de la condamnation mais ne
suffisent pas et c'est la raison pour
laquelle nous devons travailler en
particulier sur le moment de la
formation
au moment où je vous parle aujourd'hui
même si les formations sont suspendus
dans le cadre du combat contre le coc
vide et que tous les élèves qui étaient
en formation sont sur le terrain
dignement fermement
mais au moment où je vous parle dans les
formations aujourd'hui aucun élève n'a
pas un temps de formation soit la
question de la lutte contre le racisme
contre l'antisémitisme depuis peu de
temps
l'adil cra la licra interviennent au
sein même des formations pour que chacun
ait conscience que dans la police
républicaine
jamais nous n'accepterons le racisme
merci monsieur le ministre la parole est
à monsieur roland lescure
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre de l'europe et des affaires
étrangères au mois de mars
notre planète s'est littéralement arrêté
tourné en un mois plus de la moitié de
la population mondiale s'est retrouvé
confiner les avions cloués au sol des
dizaines et des dizaines de frontières
ont été fermées laissant nombre de nos
compatriotes bloqués loin de la france
chacun d'entre vous dans vos
circonscriptions en moyenne c'est plus
de 300 français qui ont été rapatriés
grâce à l'action du ministère de
l'europe et des affaires étrangères au
total 180 mille de nos concitoyens ont
été rapatriés pour vous donner un ordre
de grandeur de comparaison les états
unis dans le même temps ont rapatrié
80000 de leurs concitoyens alors
monsieur le ministre je tiens a commencé
cette question par vous remercier et à
travers vous remercier l'ensemble des
personnels consulaires et des personnels
du quai d'orsay qui ont permis cet
exploit et puis j'ai deux questions pour
vous monsieur le ministre vous avez
annoncé la semaine dernière avec votre
collègue de l'action les comptes publics
et jean-baptiste lemoyne votre
secrétaire d'état que vous souhaitiez
aller plus loin pour soutenir nos
compatriotes à l'étranger en un an sans
220 millions d'euros dead
au delà des 20 millions déjà dépensés
pour le rapatriement pour des raisons
sociales sanitaires et d'éducation donc
j'aimerais monsieur le ministre que vous
donniez plus de détails sur ce
dispositif là aussi unique au monde que
vous avez annoncé
et puis deuxième question dans le cadre
du dispositif d'urgence que nous en
sommes que nous sommes pardon en train
d'examiner dans cette au sénat et
bientôt dans cet hémicycle
le gouvernement a souhaité mettre en
place une quatorzaine pour les voyageurs
rentrant en france en provenance de pays
en dehors de l'espace économique
européen
on comprend bien dans cette période de
déconfinement l'objectif premier est de
limiter la circulation du virus
d'où la logique de cette décision pour
autant vous savez monsieur le ministre
les zones du monde où une circulation
très diverses certains nos chronos
français nos codes compatriote pardon
doivent rentrer en france pour des
raisons impérieuses notamment
malheureusement pour assister à des
obsèques et donc j'aimerais monsieur le
ministre que vous donniez plus de
détails sur cette mesure merci
merci chers collègues la parole de
monsieur jean yves le drian ministre de
l'europe et les affaires étrangères oui
merci monsieur le député lescure d'abord
merci pour avoir salué le travail des
équipes de mon ministère à la fois au
centre de crise et dans les postes ce
travail a permis de favoriser le retour
282000 aujourd'hui de nos ressortissants
qui étaient à l'étranger parfois dans
des conditions extrêmes que sur la
cordillère des andes dans les
philippines pour revenir sur deux sujets
qui m'ont particulièrement préoccupés je
voudrais vous dire aussi que concernant
nos compatriotes qui résident à
l'étranger
nous leur avons recommandé comme
d'ailleurs tous les pays européens de
rester dans le pays où ils ont élu
domicile mais bien sûr cela n'a de sens
que si nous pouvons leur apporter le
soutien nécessaire soutien sanitaire
soutien social souci un soutien éducatif
et c'est la raison pour laquelle deux
sous l'autorité du premier ministre nous
avons proposé avec gérald darmanin
jean-baptiste lemoyne un plan qui permet
à la fois de d'assurer un soutien un
dispositif médical spécifique qui est
dès à présent déployer soit par le biais
de télésuivi de les consultations de
médicaments d'évacuation sanitaire
potentiel un ensemble cohérent soit par
un soutien social à l'égard des familles
françaises les plus affectées à la fois
par un dispositif de
bourses scolaires et un dispositif dette
sociale directe qui rouvriront à peu
près 100 millions d'euros et enfin par
un soutien la ffe qui aidera tous les
établissements gestion directe
conventionné ou partenaires et qui
aidera toutes les familles françaises et
étrangères pour par un financement
supplémentaire de 100 millions d'euros
grâce à une avance de france trésor dont
nous avons établi un dispositif cohérent
concernant les mesures de 14 n je vous
reprécise mais vous le savez déjà que le
projet de loi de prorogation de l'état
d'urgence actuellement débattu au
parlement rend possible juridiquement
rend possible juridiquement leur
adoption pour toute personne entrant en
france si le besoin s'en fait sentir
pour des motifs sanitaires à l'égard de
tel ou tel pays mais à l'intérieur de
l'espace européen à ce stade compte tenu
de l'évolution actuelle de la pandémie
ces mesures de 14 n non pas adepte
appliqué à ce stade merci monsieur le
ministre la parole à madame d'humains
gaudérique dumas merci monsieur le
président ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le premier ministre
le site du gouvernement propose depuis
fin avril une nouvelle page intitulée d
un fox coronavirus cette rubrique
propose de fait de labelliser ce qui est
fiable et ce qui ne l'est pas en
sélectionnant une liste d'articles et ce
sans même l'autorisation des rédactions
concernées ce qui donne une idée de la
valeur que vous donnez au droit moral
des auteurs que vous prétendez par
ailleurs protégé
le gouvernement propose de faire des
choix en s'abritant artificiellement
derrière les rubriques dit de fact
checking des rédactions et de choisir
donc les titres de presse que l'on peut
lire et ce que l'on ne peut pas lire les
plus graves en quand vous venez heurté
de plein fouet les principes qui doivent
le pratique qui doit demeurer intangible
de l'indépendance de la presse qui
s'exerce notamment à travers la liberté
le pluralisme et sous l'oeil critique
des lecteurs j'ajoute c'était et c'est
tout aussi triste que cette initiative
est par ailleurs inefficace voire
contre-productive
compte tenu la chute de confiance des
français dans la capacité du
gouvernement à gérer la crise et à
délivrer des informations fiables
non seulement les français qui doutent
n'iront jamais sur un site
gouvernemental pour démêler le vrai du
faux mais le risque est grand d'inciter
la population à s'informer en dehors des
sources mise soit disant en valeur par
le gouvernement par ailleurs cette
initiative intervient après la loi dite
fait qu news ou encore la loi sur le
secret des affaires
qui pose la question de la liberté
d'expression et de la capacité des
journalistes à mener librement leurs
investigations
elle fait également écho à la volonté du
président de la république je le cite de
certifier déontologiquement les organes
de presse concrétiser en décembre
dernier par l'idée d'un conseil de
déontologie journalistique et de
médiation enfin le fait écho à la
volonté de mettre en place
quoi qu'il en coûte l'application
numérique de traçage stop covin un
ensemble de dispositifs assurément
inefficace et potentiellement
liberticide qui s'ajoutent les uns aux
autres monsieur premier ministre après
l'état d'urgence sanitaire économique et
social il est venu le temps de déclarer
à la fois l'état d'urgence culturel
comme isabelle adjani l'a si bien
appeler de ses voeux ce matin et il est
temps de déclarer l'état d'urgence
démocratique
je vous demande donc si vous allez
prendre la décision de simple bon sens
qui s'imposent de supprimer
immédiatement cette rubrique du site sur
le site du gouvernement qui n'a pas lieu
d'être
quelles que soient les circonstances et
qui dépend de vous merci la parole est à
monsieur franck reister ministre de la
culture
[Musique]
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés madame la députée
dumas la problème la prolifération d un
fox des fausses informations est un
véritable danger pour la santé nos
compatriotes pour notre démocratie pour
la société toute entière
depuis plusieurs mois à la demande du
présent la république et sous l'autorité
du premier ministre le gouvernement se
mobilise pour lutter contre ces
désinformations et c'est une fausse
information
d'où la loi sur la manipulation de
l'information qui visait à
responsabiliser les plateformes et nos
mettre en place des dispositifs
spécifiques dans les périodes
préélectorales le gouvernement salue
toutes les initiatives et les sont
nombreuses qui sont prises par toutes
les rédactions pour lutter contre cette
des fausses informations à la fois par
des équipes dédiées des rubriques
dédiées
j'ai été moi même visité les services
des fp factuelle qui a beaucoup investi
la fp dans la lutte contre les fausses
informations
avec notamment des dispositifs très
puissants de lutte contre l'hypertrophie
cage qui est une des nouvelles
techniques de désinformation et bien
évidemment le service qui était proposée
par le porte parole à qui visait
simplement à apporter un service
élémentaire pour regrouper sous une même
page les disposent les ressources de
lutte contre la désinformation
concernant la crise sanitaire ne
représentait évidemment pas un objectif
de tri de d'articles ou d'information
pour autant je peux comprendre les
inquiétudes qui ont été suscitées par ce
service dans les rédactions
parce qu'il ne s'agit absolument pas
pour l'état de labelliser les médias ou
d'orienter le choix des français vers
tel ou tel média en tant que ministre de
la culture garant de la liberté de la
presse
garant de son indépendance et du
pluralisme de la presse je souhaite donc
vous annoncer que le gouvernement a pris
la décision de retirer cette page du
site du gouvernement
j'en profite enfin pour saluer le
travail remarquable des journalistes
pendant la crise qui ont contribué
malgré les difficultés à informer nos
compatriotes et à lutter efficacement
contre les des informations merci la
parole est à monsieur thierry benoit
uniquement lui il avait la peau
recherche merci monsieur le président
madame la garde des sceaux alors que le
déconfinement se dessine chacun de nous
doit être pleinement mobilisé pour
relancer la france il s'agit de remettre
notre pays en état de marche est plus
que jamais dans un contexte aussi
particulier nous avons besoin de
souplesse de pragmatisme
bref en un mot de bon sens la vie la vie
économique doit reprendre mais elle doit
elle a besoin de confiance cette vie
cette vie économique et non d'une
suspicion généralisée aussi qu'on veille
à faire respecter les règles sanitaires
et les gestes barrière c'est
indispensable et nécessaire mais que des
actions de jeu en justice puisse être
intentée pendant l'urgence sanitaire
cela pose question la notion de faute
non intentionnelle doit être prise en
compte
même la carte des sceaux beaucoup de
personnes en responsabilité chef
d'entreprise chefs d'établissements
scolaires artisans commerçants maires
présidents de départements président de
région formule aujourd'hui une crainte
la crainte d'engager leur responsabilité
civile et pénale pour un virus que non
seulement il
on pas choisi mais contre lequel il
lutte de toutes leurs forces
il y a donc aujourd'hui urgence à
sécuriser la relance économique et
limiter l'incertitude juridique
la directive européenne du 12 juin 89
prévoit en son article 5 que les états
membres peuvent prévoir l'exclusion ou
la diminution de la responsabilité des
employeurs dans des circonstances
exceptionnelles
madame la garde des sceaux quelles
dispositions le gouvernement entend t-il
activé pour cette question de sécurité
juridique
je crois que les personnes en
responsabilité qu'ils soient
entrepreneurs qu'ils soient élus ont
besoin aujourd'hui d'une réponse la plus
précise possible de la part du
gouvernement
je vous remercie merci chers collègues
la parole est à madame nicole belloubet
garde des sceaux ministre de la justice
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés monsieur le député
benoist le gouvernement partage bien
entendu votre approche il est essentiel
comme vous l'avez souligné que nous
puissions pleinement mobilisé l'ensemble
de nos ressources c'est-à-dire aussi de
nos décideurs qu'ils soient chefs
d'entreprises responsables associatifs
élus pour participer à cette phase assez
singulière et qui suppose beaucoup
d'énergie partagée de déconfinement et
cela ils doivent le faire dans toute la
sérénité juridiques possibles avec le
plus de sérénité je redis possible je
tiens toutefois ici à faire remarquer
que quelles que soient les textes
quelles que soient les textes nous
n'empêcherons pas et d'une certaine
manière c'est heureux c'est le principe
de la démocratie
nous n'empêcherons jamais que se
déclenche des procédures cet autre chose
que de savoir si elles peuvent aboutir
comme j'ai eu l'occasion de le répond
tout à l'heure aux députés cubertafon et
je ne reprends pas ici mon raisonnement
la responsabilité pénale est assez
complexe et strictes a engagé j'ai dit
les raisons pour lesquelles c'était le
cas elles ne permettent pas les règles
du code pénal de mettre en jeu aisément
la responsabilité j'ai dit toutefois que
nous étions ouf
r à travailler sur ce sujet vous évoquez
également la responsabilité du chef
d'entreprise vis-à-vis de ses salariés
au plan civil
là encore jamais eu l'occasion de
répondre à une question ici même je
crois en disant que depuis une
jurisprudence air france de 2015
les choses sont stabilisés du point de
vue du droit ça a été réaffirmée par
l'assemblée plénière de la cour de
cassation en 2019
il est jugé désormais de manière
constante que l'employeur qui a pris les
mesures de prévention nécessaires
respecte ses obligations légales et peut
donc s'exonérer de sa responsabilité
civile
vous évoquez aussi la directive de 1989
sur l'amélioration de la santé des
travailleurs qui permet à l'employeur
qui permet à l'employeur de voir sa
responsabilité limitée pour des causes
étrangères ou en cas de circonstances
exceptionnelles
cette directive permet une exonération
mais elle ne l'imposent pas et il me
semble qu'il vaut mieux de ce point de
vue rester sur la jurisprudence air
france dont je parlais tout à l'heure
mais au fond il n'y a pas de suspicion
généralisée de ce point de vue là mais
nous sommes prêts je les dis à
accompagner tout débat qui apparaîtrait
nécessaire merci madame la garde des
sceaux
permettez-moi d'observer qu'il est 17h25
et qu'après le 11 mai nous reprenons nos
habitudes avec des questions à deux
minutes des réponses à deux minutes
sinon ensuite les mêmes qui réclament de
venir en grand nombre cet hémicycle de
nous quitte de manière prématurée la
séance des questions au gouvernement est
terminée je vous remercie le sortir de
manière échelonnée prochaine séance
jeudi 7 mai à 9h projet de loi
prorogeant l'état d'urgence sanitaire
la séance est levée